FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE ONE
ON EDUCATION TO ORDER. AND LET
ME GO THROUGH A FEW OF OUR
PROCESSES FOR TODAY. IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERED NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES
WE MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERING SYNOD HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
HEARINGS TODAY IN THE CAPITAL
SENATOR OR CHOI BOGUE WILL BE
JOINING US SHORTLY. AND I NEED
TO APOLOGIZE FOR CENTER MEN WHO
CANNOT BE HERE TODAY BUT JUST
LET YOU KNOW HE GAVE ME FIVE
QUESTIONS THAT I WILL LAST
THROUGHOUT THE HEARING. A TO
REPRESENT HIS CONCERNS ON THIS
ISSUE. THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I S. THAT
EVERYTIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USED TO
RAISE THE HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK TO A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE PLEASE
SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING. R. I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN
YOU ARE DONE. ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT YOU
CAN BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE
YOUR NAME AND THEN YOU ARE READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO
ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE HEARING ROOM. TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PERFECT
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER.
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN I SEE IT
THERE NOW. AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBERS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX THREE.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE SIX THREE. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. 736-283-3736 TWO
EIGHT THREE THREE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WILL WEBSITE. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT AND
TODAY WE HAVE SEVEN ISSUES AND
WILL BE TAKING PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE CONCLUSION OF THE SEVENTH
ISSUE. YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE TEN ZERO.
PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER.
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LONG NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LONG
NUMBER. THAT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
ON MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW READY
TO ADDRESS TO COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING THE
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. BOB AND I WILL MAKE A
JUDGMENT. AT THE END OF THE
SEVEN ISSUES AND HOW MUCH TIME
WE HAVE LEFT. AS TO WHETHER OR
NOT TO LIMIT OF. THE TESTIMONY
EITHER A NUMBER OF CALLERS OR IN
TIME FROM THE TESTIMONY. WE
REALLY WANT TO HEAR FROM
EVERYONE AND I DO WANT TO LET
EVERYONE KNOW THAT. EVEN IF YOU
HAVE TO LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS. OR
PART LIMITED IN SOME WAY. WE
ACCEPT TESTIMONY. IN WRITING TO
THE COMMITTEE. AND SO EITHER WAY
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HEAR
FROM YOU. ALL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY. AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTION BUTTE.
IN TWO HEARING. WHICH IS THE
FOURTH OF TEN HEARINGS AND FOUR
AND A HALF WEEKS OF THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE WE HAVE THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WAS
SEVEN DISCUSSION ITEMS WERE
FIRST DISCUSSED THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET AND SEVERAL
PROPOSALS COVERED OVERSIGHT ITEM
ON THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE NATURAL RESOURCES
WILL ALSO DISCUSS SEVERAL
IMPLEMENTATION UPDATES RELATED
TO PREVIOUS BUDGET ACT
AGREEMENTS. FINALLY WE WILL
DISCUSS UC'S UPDATE RELATED TO
THE HIGHER EDUCATION A STUDENT
HOUSING PROGRAM. AND SO WITH
THAT. A WE WILL MOVE TO. ISSUE
NUMBER ONE A WHICH IS AN
OVERVIEW AND- WE HAVE TODAY. OF
BRIAN RUTLEDGE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE A JASON
CONSTANT TOURISTS FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST AND SAY HI
VIRTANEN THE ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR
OF THE STATE BUDGET OF STATE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS. OF FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND- I
DON'T SEE ANY COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES SO WE WILL MOVE TO
THE FIRST ITEM AND WE WILL TAKE
THOSE IN THAT ORDER SO- MR
RUTLEDGE ARE WELCOME TO THE
COMMISSION. BRIAN RUTLEDGE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR LAYER PLEASURE TO
BE HERE. SOLVE ALL BE BRIEF THIS
MORNING I KNOW THERE'S SEVERAL
BIG ISSUES YOU WANT TO TALK
ABOUT. THE BIG CONTACTS THIS
YEAR THAT'S DIFFERENT FROM
PREVIOUS YEARS IS THAT.
ADMINISTRATION IS INTRODUCING A
MULTI YEAR COMPACT WITH THE UC.
SO THIS COMPACT WOULD LAST FROM. TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE TO
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN THAT'S
FIVE FISCAL YEARS. IT'S BASED.
ARE YOU ON THE UC TWENTY THIRTY
GOALS THAT THE SEGMENT HAD
ALREADY BEEN DEVELOPING ITS
BROADLY ALIGNED WITH THE CSU
COMPACT IN THE CCC ROAD MAP AND
ULTIMATELY WORKS TOWARDS GREATER
ACCESS EQUITY AND AFFORDABILITY
. SO THE INVESTMENTS LIST IN THE
SECOND ARE COMING WITH THE
EXPECTATION THAT YOU SEE WORKS
ON. THE WHOLE SET OF
EXPECTATIONS AND UNLIKE PREVIOUS
YEARS WHEN THERE HAVE BEEN-
SEVERAL BIG EXPECTATIONS ON I
CAN'T REALLY GO THROUGH ALL OF
THEM BECAUSE AS DETAILED IN THE
EIGHT PAGES WE HAVE A LOT OF US
SUBSTANTIAL EXPECTATIONS HERE
THAT COME WITH THE COMPACT. ALL
JUSTIFIED THE BIG CATEGORIES OF
EXPECTATIONS SO WE HAVE
EXPECTATIONS THAT FALL UNDER
ACCESS EQUITY AFFORDABILITY
INTERSEGMENT OF COORDINATION.
WORKFORCE PREPAREDNESS AND
ONLINE EDUCATION AND JUST A
SINGLE OUT ONE CATEGORY THERE
FOR SOME DETAILS THE ACCESS
COMPONENT INCLUDES EXPECTATIONS
AROUND ENROLLMENT GROWTH. THAT
WOULD BE FULLY FUNDING THE
UNDERGRADUATE GROWTH- SPECIFIED
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
AND THEN ON TOP OF THAT CREATING
ANNUAL 1% GROWTH- SO ALL
EXPECTATIONS THAT ARE OUTSIDE IN
THE EIGHT PAGES UNDER THOSE
CATEGORIES. THEY'RE TIED TO THE
BIG PROPOSALS IN THE ACTUAL
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE FISCAL
YEAR THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THIS
YEAR WE HAVE- MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED MILLION ONGOING
PROPOSED- GENERAL FUND INCREASES
FOR YOU SEE WE ALSO HAVE ALMOST
THREE HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATIONS. ALL
LIST THE ON GOING AND ONE TIMES
HERE. THE BIGGEST ONES OUR
BIGGEST ONGOING GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATION IS WE'RE PROPOSING
IS TWO HUNDRED POINT FIVE
MILLION I'LL BE FOR A 5% BASED
AUGMENTATION. AND A TIE THIS TO
THE MULTI YEAR AGREEMENT THE
MULTI YEAR CONTACT. EACH YEAR
DURING THE FIVE FISCAL YEARS THE
PROPOSAL IS FOR A 5% BASED
AUGMENTATION THIS TWENTY TO TWO
HUNDRED POINT FIVE MILLION IS
THE FIRST UNDER PROPOSED.
SEVERAL YEARS OF SIMILAR
AUGMENTATIONS. OUR CONTINGENT ON
THE UC. MAKING PROGRESS TOWARDS
THE AGREED UPON GOALS. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES
SIXTY SEVEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
. TO FIND SIXTY TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY UNDERGRADUATE RESIDENT
SLOTS THAT'S PURSUANT TO THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACTS
WERE ESSENTIALLY PROPOSING TO
FULLY FUND WHAT WAS IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. BUDGET ACTED
INTENT LANGUAGE WE'RE ALSO
PROPOSING- THIRTY ONE MILLION
ONGOING GENERAL FUND. TO FUND A
NON RESIDENT- REVENUE BACK FILL
BECAUSE THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT INCLUDED EXPECTATIONS
ABOUT REDUCING NONRESIDENT.
ENROLLMENT OR AT LEAST THE
PROPORTION. WORK WHAT WE'RE FOR
FOSTER YOUTH PROGRAMS THERE WAS
THERE ARE PARALLEL INVESTMENTS
IN THE CSU IN C. SIXTIES AS
WELL- FASTER YOU. WE'RE
PROPOSING TO MILLION FOR
FIREARMS RESEARCH AT UC DAVIS.
AND WE'RE PROPOSING A TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT TO THE GME OF THE
GRADUATE PROGRAM BACK FILL TO
KEEP THE PROGRAM AT FORTY
MILLION TOTAL RESOURCES FOR YOU
SEE. WE HAVE THREE ONE TIME
PROPOSALS AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. THE BIGGEST IS A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY FIVE MILLION FOR
THREE CLIMATE INVESTMENTS. SO
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
ENTIRE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ACROSS
MANY POLICY AREAS THERE'S
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS WORTH OF
VARIOUS INVESTMENTS THAT ARE
FOCUSED ON. MITIGATING CLIMATE
CHANGE. ADAPTING TO CLIMATE
CHANGE AND THEN ALSO CREATING
ECONOMIC INCLUSION AND GROWTH
VIA THOSE PROPOSALS SO THIS ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
WE'RE PROPOSING FOR YOU SEE PART
OF A MUCH BROADER PACKAGE- THAT
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
THOUGHT THROUGH. THE ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE IS MADE UP OF A
HUNDRED MILLION FOR A SEATING
MATCHING GRANT. PROGRAM THAT
WOULD THAT WOULD CREATE NEW
APPLIED CLIMATE FOCUSED RESEARCH
FIFTY MILLION FOR REGIONAL
INCUBATORS TO DRIVE CLIMATE
FOCUSED ENTREPRENEURSHIP. AND
THIRTY FIVE MILLION FOR REGIONAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT TRAINING
HUBS AND THOSE WOULD BE
COLOCATED WITH THE INCUBATORS
FOR ENTREPRENEURSHIP. SO THE
OTHER TWO ONE TIME INVESTMENTS
THERE'S A HUNDRED MILLION
PROPOSED FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY. AND TEN MILLION FOR
DYSLEXIA RESEARCH AT UCSF. WHICH
BUILDS ARE. INVESTMENTS THE
STATE HAS MADE. SO I WILL I WILL
IN THERE AND I WE'RE OPEN FOR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTRUST LEDGE. OF AND WE'RE
HOLD ALL QUESTIONS TILL ALL
THREE PANELISTS OF SPOKEN WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE. HI GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE JASON KAHN CENTER LOS
LA- YOUR FIRST ISSUE HERE IS
REALLY FOCUSED ON THAT- FIRST
PROPOSAL FROM THE GOVERNOR-
WHICH IS AT 5% BASED INCREASED
AMOUNTING TO ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. OUR FOCUS MY
COMMENTS ON THAT SPECIFIC
PROPOSAL- YOU'LL HE'LL- SOME OF
THE OTHER PROPOSALS AND
SUBSEQUENT ITEMS AND ALSO AND-
THAT'S WHAT HEARING. I SPEECH
FOR YOUR AGENDA NOTES. IN
ADDITION TO THE PROPOSED GENERAL
FUND BASED AUGMENTATION YOU SEE
ALSO EXPECTS TO RECEIVE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING- FROM ITS
PLAN TO INCREASE STUDENT TUITION
. THE GENERAL FUND BASED
INCREASED AND TUITION COMBINED
WOULD AMOUNT TO ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX MILLION
THE NEW BASE SUPPORT FOR THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. PAGE SIX
OF YOUR AGENDA SUMMARIZES OUR-
ASSESSMENT RECOMMENDATIONS. ARE
KEY RECOMMENDATION HERE IS OF
THE LEGISLATURE TAKE A DIFFERENT
APPROACH TO BUDGETING FOR YOU
SEE THAN WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSES. WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER. WITH THE
SPECIFIC COST INCREASES IN
PRIORITIES THAT WOULD LIKE TO
FUND ANTI AUGMENTATIONS TO
THOSE- ESTIMATED INCREASES.
RATHER THAN ADOPTING ARBITRARY
5% OR SOME OTHER PERCENT
INCREASE WE THINK THAT APPROACH.
WOULD OFFER MORE TRANSPARENCY
INTO THE LEGISLATURE GREATER
CONFIDENCE AS TO WHAT IT
SPECIFICALLY FUNDING. WOULD ALSO
THINK IT WOULD JUST LINE FOR
MORE RATIONAL BUDGET DISCUSSION
. THE PLACE TO START WITH-
DECIDING BASED INCREASES WITH
UC'S OPERATING COSTS- YOU SEE
HAS WHAT YOU MIGHT CONSIDER SOME
VERY BASIC OPERATING COST
INCREASES. BUT IT WOULD STILL
HAVE TO PAY FOR REGARDLESS OF
HOW MUCH FUNDING IT GETS THESE
ARE THINGS LIKE EMPLOYEE BENEFIT
COST INCREASES INCREASES TO ITS
OPERATING EXPENSES AND
EQUIPMENT. BY DEBT SERVICE COST
INCREASES AND THEN ON TOP OF
THAT THE UNIVERSITY ALSO FEATURE
FACES DECISIONS AROUND HOW MUCH
YOU SUPPORT IN FACT AND-
FOUNDRESSES FOR FACULTY AND
STAFF. NO I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT WE DON'T HAVE A HARD
RECOMMENDATION ON THE EXACT
BASED INCREASED PROVIDE YOU SEE
IN. THE BUDGET YEAR THAT'S NOT
REALLY FALL ON THE LEGISLATURE'S
PRIORITIES FOR YOU SEE AND THE
SPECIFIC COST INCREASES WOULD
LIKE TO SUPPORT. ALSO EMPHASIZED
THAT. IT A LITTLE LEGISLATURE
AFTER LOOKING AT UC'S COST
INCREASES. WE MIGHT LOOK AT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BASE
AUGMENTATION WHICH WE ESTIMATE
WOULD COVER A UC'S BASIC
OPERATING COST INCREASES AND
CLOSE TO A 4% INCREASE AT ITS-
ALWAYS SELL RIPPLE. I THINK THAT
AUGMENTATION IS REASONABLE OUR
POINT IS THAT OF THOSE COSTS
SHOULD BE DRIVING THE DECISIONS
NOT SOME ARBITRARY PERCENT THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED
. THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE
CAUTIOUS ABOUT. COMMITTING TO
FUTURE ARBITRARY INCREASES AND
CONTINUE TO REVIEW INFORMATION
AS IT BECOMES AVAILABLE WAY IT'S
PRIORITIES EACH YEAR AND ASSESS
ITS BUDGET SITUATION SURE WHEN
DECIDING HOW MUCH FUNDING TO
PROVIDE YOU SEE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHOULD NOW
WILL MOVE ON TO THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. GOOD MORNING CHIRLA
OR THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY. I'M SAY EVER TALENT
REPRESENTING THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S THANKFUL TO
GOVERNOR NEWSOM BURKE THE
SUBSTANTIAL BUDGET INTRODUCTION.
THE PROPOSED 5% ANNUAL BASE
BUDGET INCREASES FOR FIVE YEARS
. RIGHTS AND SUPPORT FOR THE
UNIVERSITY AS WE UNDERTAKE
IMPORTANT AN AMBITIOUS GOALS FOR
ACCESS EQUITY AND AFFORDABILITY
. THE PARTNERSHIP THE UNIVERSITY
HAS HAD WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR IN RECENT YEARS HAS
ALLOWED US TO ENROLL THOUSANDS
OF NEW CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATES
INCREASE THE AVAILABILITY OF
MEDICAL EDUCATION AND CONDUCT
RESEARCH ON ISSUES IMPACTING THE
LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS IN EVERY
PART OF THE STATE. FROM
AGRICULTURE TO HEALTH THE
CHILDREN'S LEARNING LOSS. THESE
ACHIEVEMENTS HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE
BECAUSE THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR CHOSE TO INVEST IN
HIGHER EDUCATION WE ASK THAT YOU
CONTINUE THIS PARTNERSHIP AND
SUPPORTING OUR SHARED GOALS FOR
THE UNIVERSITY'S EXCELLENCE. WE
HAVE BEEN LIVING WITH A
YEARS OUR FACULTY AND STUDENTS
HAVE ADJUSTED TO CHANGING
INSTRUCTIONAL MODALITIES AND OUR
STAFF HAVE KEPT THE CAMPUS
OPERATIONS AND SERVICES GOING
STRONG. OUR MEDICAL CENTERS HAVE
TENDED TO PATIENTS PROVIDED
VACCINES AND CONDUCTED RESEARCH
ON CODE AND ITS IMPACT. THE
ENTIRE UNIVERSITY COMMUNITY HAS
RESPONDED ADMIRABLY AND CONTINUE
TO CONTRIBUTE POSITIVELY TO
CALIFORNIA. THE STATE'S FISCAL
AND POLICY CONTRIBUTIONS THE
UNIVERSITY HELPED THIS
FLEXIBILITY DURING THESE
CHALLENGING TIMES. THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IS A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF THE STATE'S
ECONOMY AS THE THIRD LARGEST
EMPLOYER IN THE STATE WITH AN
ESTIMATED TOTAL BUDGET OF FORTY
FOUR BILLION IN THE CURRENT
YEAR. THE UNIVERSITY PROVIDES
EDUCATION RESEARCH AND PUBLIC
SERVICES THAT TOUCH ON THE LIVES
OF ALL CALIFORNIANS TODAY I WILL
DISCUSS OUR CORE FUNDS BUDGET
WITH YOU. THIS IS THE COMPONENT
OF THE UNIVERSITY'S BUDGET THAT
FUNDS ARE CAMPUS OPERATIONS
INCLUDING ANSWER. AND IS
COMPOSED OF GENERAL. TUITION
FEES NONRESIDENTS TUITION AND A
FEW SMALLER FUNDS. THE CORE
FUNDS BUDGET FOR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO IS ESTIMATED AT TEN
POINT FIVE BILLION. FOR BILLION
OF THIS CORE OPERATING BUDGET IS
PROVIDED AS ONGOING STATE
GENERAL FUNDS. ANOTHER ONE
BILLION COMES IN DIRECTLY FROM
THE STATE IN THE FORM OF CAL
GRANTS AND MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIPS TO COVER STUDENTS
TUITION. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES FOUR POINT THREE
BILLION AN ONGOING STATE GENERAL
FUND AND TWO HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
MILLION AND ONE TIMES FUNDS FOR
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
FOR TOTAL BUDGET OF FOUR POINT
SIX BILLION. THE PROPOSED 5%
BASED BUDGET INCREASE WOULD
PROVIDE THE UNIVERSITY WITH TWO
HUNDRED POINT FIVE MILLION IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE.
ASSISTING CAMPUS OPERATIONS AND
HELP THE UNIVERSITY UNDERTAKE
POLICY GOALS FOR ACCESS EQUITY
AFFORDABILITY AND COLLABORATION
WITH COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND CSU
. THE CAMPUS OPERATING COST
INCREASES THAT THE UNIVERSITY
FACES INCLUDE CONTRACTUALLY
COMMITTED REPRESENTED LABOR
SALARY INCREASES DEBT SERVICE ON
OUR BUILDINGS FACULTY HIM POLICY
COVERED STAFF SALARY INCREASES
AND GENERAL OPERATING
INFLATIONARY PRESSURES. THE
PROPOSED BASED BUDGET INCREASES
FOR THE NEXT FIVE YEARS COUPLED
WITH THE UNIVERSITY'S COURT
BASED TUITION ADJUSTMENTS WILL
PROVIDE TO UNIVERSITY WITH
RESEARCH STABILITY TO GROW
ENROLLMENT RESPONSIBLY. MAKE
FURTHER PROGRESS ON CLOSING
GRADUATION GAPS AND BEGIN
OFFERING DEBT FREE EDUCATION
OPTIONS. IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE A COURT BASED TUITION AND
FEES ARE ESTIMATED TO PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL FORTY FIVE MILLION IN
OPERATING REVENUE AND THIRTY
THREE POINT SEVEN MILLION IN
FINANCIAL AID. RECOGNIZING THAT
ACCESS MUST BE PARTNERED WITH
SUCCESS THE RETURNS HAVE SET A
GOAL AND OUTLINED IMPLEMENTATION
STRATEGIES FOR CLOSING
GRADUATION GAPS. WHILE THE
CURRENT FOR YOUR OVERALL
GRADUATION RATE IS SEVENTY TWO
POINT 6% THE FOUR YEAR
GRADUATION RATE FOR UNDER
REPRESENTED GROUPS IS SIXTY TWO
POINT THREE PERCENT. THE
UNIVERSITY WANTS TO ENHANCE
STUDENT ACADEMIC PREPARATION
ADVISING AND TUTORING BOLSTER
ANALYTICAL TOOLS TO ALLOW FOR
EARLY ACADEMIC INTERVENTION. AND
SUPPORT ANIMATIONS AND
INSTRUCTIONAL DELIVERY AS
METHODS FOR CLOSING THIS
GRADUATION CAP. IN THE BUDGET
ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
LEGISLATURE DEVELOP NEW
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS TO REDUCE
THE COST OF HIGHER EDUCATION FOR
STUDENTS. UNIVERSITY SHARES THIS
BOWL OF BAK FREE EDUCATION WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR. PRESIDENT DRAKE HAS
DISCUSSED HIS INTENT TO MOVE
TOWARD STEP FREE EDUCATION AND
WITH THE ASSISTANCE OF STATE AND
FEDERAL FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS
WE WILL BEGIN MAKING PROGRESS ON
THIS GOAL. AS STATE INVESTMENTS
AND FINANCIAL AID GROW SO WILL
OUR PROGRAMS TO OFFER ADDITIONAL
ASSISTANCE TO OUR STUDENTS.
THESE FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS
COMBINED WITH THE STABILITY
PROVIDED BY THE UNIVERSITY'S
COHORT BASED TUITION WILL
PROVIDE ASSURANCE TO OUR
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES THAT
THEY CAN AFFORD HIGHER
EDUCATION. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
ALSO ESTABLISHES GOALS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY'S COLLABORATION WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND CSU. THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN INCREASING INTER SEGMENTAL
COLLABORATION IN RECENT YEARS
WITH TWENTY ONE ESTABLISHED
TRANSFER PATHWAYS FROM COMMUNITY
COLLEGE THE UC STUDENT ACADEMIC
PREPARATION AN EDUCATIONAL
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS TO PREPARE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS WERE
TRANSFERRED TO CSU OR UC. AND
WORKING WITH PARTNERS STATE
AGENCIES ON THE BLUEPRINT FOR
THE CRADLE TO CAREER SYSTEM. THE
COLLABORATION GOALS OUTLINED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCREASE
THESE COLLABORATIONS AND
LEVERAGE THE STRENGTHS OF EACH
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENT.
WITH THE SHARED GOALS IN MIND
THE UNIVERSITY REQUEST FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BASE BUDGET INCREASE OF
5% THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OUR WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO QUESTIONS IN A AND I NEED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE I MENTIONED EARLIER
THAT SENATOR MAN. CANNOT BE WITH
US AND HE GAVE ME A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS TO ASK ON THIS ITEM
BUT A THIS IS PROBABLY THE BROAD
OVERVIEW AND THIS IS A PLACE
WHERE MANY THINGS FALL THEREFORE
THEY'LL BE MANY QUESTIONS. AND
LET ME BEGIN BY ASKING THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN YOUR
PRESENTATION HE GAVE A BROAD
BRUSH OVERVIEW. OF A COMPACT
THAT YOU'RE PROPOSING CONDITION
FOR THE 5% OF BASE INCREASE THAT
YOU ARE ALSO INCLUDING IN YOUR
BUDGET. ARE YOU GAVE AN OVERVIEW
WHEN WILL THE SPECIFIC TERMS OF
THE COMPACT BE AVAILABLE. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION- AS I AS I
MENTIONED THERE'S RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE A AGREED UPON FRAMEWORK SO
WE DO HAVE THE ACTUAL HIGH LEVEL
GOALS AGREED UPON. WHAT WE ARE
WORKING THROUGH NOW AND YOU CAN
EXPECT IT MAY REVISE OUR SOME
DETAILS ABOUT HOW TO MEASURE
AND- THEREFORE HOW DAY HOW OLD
TYPICALLY TO IMPLEMENT THESE-
AGREED UPON GOALS OF THAT WAS
GOING TO BE MY NEXT QUESTION SO
RIGHT NOW. THERE'S NO
MEASUREMENT AND THERE'S NO.
POUND ABILITY MECHANISM- BECAUSE
I THINK THE BIG QUESTION IS. IS
IF THEY DO NOT MEET THE GOALS
THAT THAT THAT YOU BOTH AGREE TO
IN THE FRAMEWORK HOW WOULD IT BE
A FORCED. ALSO WE'RE WE'RE
WORKING THROUGH THAT FOR THE MAY
REVISED UP. OKAY THEN LET ME ASK
ONE OTHER QUESTION ON THAT. DID
I HEAR YOU SAY THAT IT WAS ALSO
PREDICATED ON NO TUITION
INCREASES FROM. NO NO SIR D.
THE- FURTHER UC'S COMPACT DISCS
THE COHORT BASED TUITION UC HAD
INDEPENDENTLY ADOPTED- LAST YEAR
AND IT TO BEGIN IN BUDGET YEAR.
I THAT THAT IS PART OF THE
CONTACT THE PREMISE IS THAT DAY
ARE MOVING FORWARD WITH THAT-
AND THE RESOURCES THEY WOULD
GAIN FROM THAT I WOULD HELP
ACHIEVE ALL THE AGREED UPON
EXPECTATIONS THERE IS NOT A- I
HAD TO WISHIN HIATUS. OF PRESUME
BY- HOW THE CONTRA OF CONTACT
WOULD BE AGREED TO THAT'S
CORRECT YOU SEE IS NOT UP TO
DATE- A COHORT BASED MODEL THAT
THEY WILL ESSENTIALLY RISE WITH
INFLATION. AND THEN- LET ME JUST
MAKE A COMMENT BECAUSE- WE'RE
EXPECTED TO APPROPRIATE MONEY
BASED ON THE COMPACT AND WE
HAVEN'T SEEN THE SPECIFICS OF
THE COMPACT ACTUALLY AS THEY ARE
GOING TO BE LAID OUT AN AGREED
TO. AND I THINK WE RESERVE THE
RIGHT TO ADHERE TO WHAT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSTS SAID OR
ANYONE ELSE WITH REGARD TO OR
RIGHT TO APPROPRIATE UNTIL WE
HAVE SEEN THE SPECIFICS OF THE
COMPACT AND I JUST WANNA MAKE
THAT CLEAR I DON'T WANT TO BE
ANY SURPRISE. A AND IT WILL BE
CONCERNING IF IT JUST COMES OUT
IN A MAY REVISE AND WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO ACT IN A MATTER OF
DAYS AND THERE STILL A LACK OF.
THE SOME SO I JUST WANT TO BE
CLEAR. WE WANT TO KNOW WE WANT
CLARITY ARE WE DON'T WANT TO ACT
ON THE APPROPRIATION AND TELL
THAT EXISTS IN SO I JUST WANT TO
MAKE THAT REALLY CLEAR FOR IT IN
THE PROCESS AND- THERE IS ALSO
LOTS OF CONVERSATION OUT THERE.
AS IF THIS IS A FOREGONE
CONCLUSION AND IT MAY WELL BE
SOMETHING THAT WE AGREE WITH BUT
WE WANT TO SEE IT BEFORE WE
AGREE AND I DON'T THINK ANYBODY
SHOULD ASSUME THAT IT IS
AUTOMATICALLY BEEN AGREED TO AT
THE LEGISLATIVE LEVEL UNTIL. WE
CAN HAVE THE COMPLETE DETAILS-
SO I JUST TO DO THAT AND THEN-
IT LET ME ASK YOU SEE- IT. A. N.
THIS ACTUALLY GOES TO ONE OF THE
COMMENTS THAT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S MADE IT SEEMS TO BE
THAT WE SHOULD ALL BE HAPPY THAT
THERE'S A 5% OUT THE GATE. OUR
BASE INCREASE AND YET GIVEN
INFLATION AND INCREASE COSTS-
I'M NOT SURE 5% MEETS THE
CURRENT LEVEL OF SERVICE SAID AT
UC AND SO LET ME ASK YU SEE.
HOW YOU WOULD MEASURE THAT. AND
WHAT DO YOU THINK YOU WOULD NEED
JUST TO MOVE AHEAD AT THE SAME
LEVEL OF. OPERATIONS THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION CENTER LAYERED-
THE UC REGENTS DID REQUEST A
BASE BUDGET INCREASE OF TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS HOWEVER WE THINK THAT
WITH THE COLD HARD BASED TUITION
INCREASED AND COST CONTAINMENT
INTERNALLY AND FEATURE WITH OUR
OWN BUDGET WE CAN. WE ARE BASE
BUDGET AND NAY AND MAKE SOME
PROGRESS ON THESE GOALS THAT
HAVE BEEN OUTLINED BY THE
GOVERNOR INDIA EIGHT PAGES AND
EXCUSE ME FOR BEING A STICKLER
BUT NOTHING MAKES ME CRAZIER
THAN THE PROPOSAL BEING AND
PERCENTAGES AND THEN YOUR
RESPONSE BEING AND DOLLARS. FIND
UNDER. HOW THOSE SMASH PARDON ME
SIR THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY WILL
ONE MILLION DOLLARS REPRESENTS
ABOUT SIX POINT 3% INCREASE WE
ARE WE'RE NOT REQUESTING THAT AT
THIS TIME WE ARE REQUESTING A 5%
INCREASE FOR THE UNIVERSITY
SPOKE SPANISH WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
THE OTHER. A SOURCES OF REVENUE
HELP YOU MAKE UP THE DIFFERENCE
TO GET THROUGH THIS BUDGET YEAR
IS THAT WAS THAT WHAT YOU'RE
ACTUALLY SAYING MORTEMART
PARSING YOUR WORDS. THAT IS WHAT
I WAS SAYING SIR THAT WITH THE
COVERT BASS TUITION INCREASE
AND- WHAT IS CERTAIN INVESTMENTS
INTERNALLY AND- WATCHING OUR OWN
BUDGETS WE THINK WE CAN MEET OUR
NEEDS. EIGHT AND THEN. ANOTHER
QUESTION- HAS TO DO WITH NON
RESIDENT TUITION AND LAST YEAR
THERE WAS AN AGREEMENT- TO ACT
CAP. OVERTIME AT 18% FOR
UNDERGRADUATE NONRESIDENT
ENROLLMENT TO ALLOW FOR MORE
SPACES FOR CALIFORNIA FAMILIES.
AND I THINK THE STATISTICS JUST
FOR THE RECORD ALTHOUGH I'M NOT
SURE THEY'RE PART OF MY
QUESTION. IS IT UC BERKELEY AS A
TWENTY FOUR POINT 4% UC IRVINE
AT EIGHTEEN POINT 5% UCLA TWENTY
TWO POINT SIX PERCENT. IN SAN
DIEGO IT TWENTY TWO POINT 5% ARE
WAS GONNA ASK HER. AND WE JUST
ADOPTED THAT IN THE BUDGET LAST
JUNE WHAT THE PROGRESSES TOWARD
THAT BUT- I UNDERSTAND. THAT TO
THE CAMPUSES DID NOT MEET THE
NONRESIDENT ENROLLMENT CAP THAT
WAS SET UP FOR FALL OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND THAT PRESIDENT
DRAKE IS PLANNING ON. THE WORD
WAS PROVIDED TO ME PENALIZING I
DON'T WANNA THROW SOMEBODY IN
THE DOCK BUT THAT THERE WOULD BE
SOME ACTIONS TAKEN FOR THE TWO-
THAT THAT DID NOT COMPLY THAT
INVOLVES. DEALING WITH THE MONEY
THAT THAT IS INVOLVED THERE SO I
WAS WONDERING IF YOU COULD
UPDATE. THE COMMITTEE ON WHAT
THE PROGRESSES TOWARD THE
AGREEMENT AND DESCRIBED WHAT THE
SITUATION IS WITH REGARD TO
PRESIDENT DIRECTS DIRECTION.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION THE
PERCENTAGES THAT YOU READ
REPRESENTING YOU DO UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA REGENTS CAP ON
NONRESIDENT ENROLLMENT AT THOSE
SPECIFIC CAMPUSES. UP FOR FALL
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- A FEW THREE
CAMPUSES DID EXCEED THEIR CAPS
UP BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO STAY
WITHIN THE REGION'S CAP. AND THE
UNIVERSITY DOES NOT WANT TO-
CREATE ANY INCENTIVE FOR THESE
CAMPUSES TO COPE OVER TAX CAP.
PRESIDENT DRAKE HAS MADE THE
DECISION THAT HE WILL REMOVE ALL
OF THE NONRESIDENT SUPPLEMENTAL
TUITION ABOVE THE CAP FROM THOSE
CAMPUSES THAT WENT OVER TO CAP
I'M PROVIDED TWO CAMPUSES THAT
HAVE FEWER RESOURCES PER STUDENT
TO USE AS ONE TIME REVENUE-
THOSE CAMPUSES THAT WILL RECEIVE
THE FUNS ARE. UC SANTA CRUZ UC
MERCED UC RIVERSIDE AND THE
TOTAL ALLOCATION BEING TAKEN
AWAY FROM OUR LA SAN DIEGO AND
IRVINE IS ABOUT TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS. AND THEN WHAT YES A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION. THERE'S SOME
SITUATION AND I NEVER REMEMBER
WHAT IT'S ACTUALLY CALLED. WHERE
THERE ARE THREE CAMPUSES THAT
WERE SORT OF UNDER RESOURCE TO
HISTORICALLY COMPARED TO OTHER
CAMPUSES AND AT THAT PRESIDENT
DRACO SAID AS A LONG TERM GOAL
TO REDRESS THAT. INEQUITY TO
THOSE HAPPEN TO BE THE THREE
CAMPUSES TO WHICH THIS MORNING
WAS JUST DIRECTED TO. THAT THAT
IS CORRECT SO- WHILE OUR
CAMPUSES ALL RECEIVE THE SAME
DOLLARS PER STUDENT UNDER OUR
RETENTION FORMULA. BECAUSE THEY
HAVE A DIFFERENT MIX OF STUDENTS
AND GRADUATE STUDENT MEDICAL
STUDENTS AN UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENT- THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
NEEDED FOR DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
EDUCATION VARIES. SO SOME OTHER
CAMPUSES- THAT JOINT DON'T IN
MORE DOLLARS FOR MEDICAL
STUDENTS HAVE TRADITIONALLY
RECEIVED HELPS A LITTLE BIT
LESS. PER STUDENT ON THE WHOLE
ON THE AVERAGE ACROSS STOCK
FORMULA. WE HAVE NOW TAKEN STEPS
TO CORRECT THAT. WHERE TO REAP
BENCHING FORMULA OUR HUSBAND
WHERE REWRITING IT TO- STATE
THAT NO CAMPUS WILL GET LESS
THAN 95% OF THE- AVERAGE FOR THE
CAMPUS DOES. SO THIS SHOULD
BEGIN CORRECTING SOME OF THOSE
HISTORICAL- BUILT IN. BOB INEC
THERE ISN'T IT NEVER ASSUME OF-
HOT STUDENTS THAT WE WERE
WAITING AS- HAS BEEN AND IF I
ASK YOU THIS QUESTION HOPEFULLY
BY THE THIRD YEAR I WILL
REMEMBER WHAT'S THE NAME OF THIS
PROGRAM. HOW DO YOU DESCRIBE
THIS WHEN YOU'RE TO LOOK AT
THESE BEING ADDRESSED YEAH WE
CALL IT OUR RETENTION PROGRAM
OKAY RETENTION. I'M SURE IS
THERE SOME. SPORTS POND TO BE
MADE IN CONJUNCTION WITH THAT
BUT THE THREE ARE JUST
COINCIDENTALLY OR THREE THAT
DON'T HAVE A MEDICAL FACILITIES
RIGHT OR- IS THAT ONE OF THE
DISTINCTIONS THAT CAUSES FOR THE
DIFFERENCE. BUT THAT THAT IS
CORRECT CENTER LAYERED WHILE UC
RIVERSIDE NOW HAS A MEDICAL
SCHOOL THAT IS A RELATIVELY
RECENT ADDITION TO THAT CAMPUS-
AND UC SANTA CRUZ AND UC MERCED
DO NOT CURRENTLY HAVE MEDICAL
SCHOOLS- AND THEN- DOES THAT
MEAN THAT. IF THE CAMPUSES IN
QUESTION THAT WERE OVER THE CAP
THIS YEAR ARE OVER THE CAP NEXT
YEAR THERE WILL BE SOME SIMILAR
THING THAT HAPPENS THAT THAT'S
THE ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM THAT
THE PRESIDENT IS USING AGAINST
CAMPUSES THAT THE DUMP ME TO CAP
. THAT DECISION IS UP TO
PRESIDENT DRAKE- FOR NEXT YEAR
FALL TWENTY TWENTY TWO- UCLA AND
UC SAN DIEGO WE NEED TO REDUCE
THE LOAD THE REGION'S TOP FIVE
THREE HUNDRED STUDENTS WILL
SPEAK ABOUT THAT IN THE NEXT
ITEM. IN SOME MORE DETAIL I KNOW
THE NEXT I'D MISS IN ROMA TO.
PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE A DEFERRED
TILL THEN AND THEN LET ME ASK
ABOUT ONE OF OUR FAVORITE TOPICS
BUXBAUM- THE SUBJECT OF
CONTRACTING OUT IN THE LETTER
WAS PROVIDED THE LEGISLATURE.
DATED A JANUARY THIRTY FIRST
THAT IS A REPORT. BUDGET BEFORE
LAST AND IT WITH US FOR
INSTANCES IN WHICH- THERE WAS
SOME SPECIAL CONTRACTING OUT
THAT NEEDED TO BE CALLED OUT.
AND IF THOSE FOR INSTANCES ALL
HAPPENED IN THIS PAST FISCAL
YEAR BUT THE LETTER DOESN'T GIVE
A FULLER PICTURE OF WHAT DID
HAPPEN UNDER THE AGREEMENT IT
JUST CALLS OUT THESEFOR- COULD
YOU GIVE US AN UPDATE DOOR
CHARACTERIZATION OF HOW.
SUCCESSFUL THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN IN-
IMPLEMENTING- THE LANGUAGE THAT
CAME IN TWENTY TWENTY WITH
REGARD TO THE SUBJECT. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION SIR. S. B.
EIGHT TWENTY REQUIRED THAT FOR
THOSE BUILDINGS THAT RECEIVE
STATE GENERAL FUND FOR A CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECT ONCE THAT PROJECT
IS COMPLETE THE UNIVERSITY WOULD
CERTIFY ON THAT BUILDING GOING
BACK TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN. IF
THERE HAD BEEN ANY CONTRACTS-
FOR OUTSIDE WORK TO BE PERFORMED
BY- NON UNIVERSITY EMPLOYEES FOR
WORK THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
OTHERWISE TRADITIONALLY
PERFORMED BY ASKS ME AS SEX
BARGAINING UNIT. AND WE HAVE
BEEN REPORTING ON THOSE- ARE
THOSE INSTANCES THAT HAVE
OCCURRED AS NEW BUILDINGS HAVE
COME ONLINE THE KEY UNDER THE S.
B. EIGHT TWENTY RUBRIC- AND WE
HAVE BEEN AS THOSE BUILDINGS
HAVE BEEN COMING ONLINE WE HAVE
BEEN ELIMINATING OUR FUTURE
CONTRACTS IN THOSE BUILDINGS. SO
IN THE MOST RECENT REPORT THAT
YOU SAW THE FOR EXCEPTIONS- TWO
OF THEM ARE ON TRACK TO BE
ELIMINATED ONE MAY NOT HAVE BEEN
UNNECESSARY REPORTING TO BE CAN
WEST AND THE OTHER WE ARE
EXAMINING THOSE ARE THOSE ARE
THE EXCEPTIONS CURRENTLY. AND
THAT MEANS THAT THERE SOMEPLACE
THAT IT'S POSTED. ARE WHAT YOU
MENTIONED WITH THE GENERAL
COMPLIANCE THAT EXIST SOMEWHERE
THAT PEOPLE CAN ACCESS. THERE
REQUIREMENTS REMEASUREMENT ONLY
THE EXCEPTIONS BE REPORTED. YES
SO THEIR STATUTE REQUIRES THAT
ONLY BE EXCEPTIONS ARE REPORTED
. THANK YOU. I'M GOING TO GO TO
PASS UNDER A CHOI BOGUE AND
FENNEL ASSESS WEST WHETHER
SENATOR MEANS TO QUESTIONS ON
THIS I HAVE BEEN ASKED WHEN
SHE'S DONE SENATOR OCHO BOOK-
SENATOR. THERE'D THIS WAS WITH
THE TO OF. WHAT IS THE REASON
FOR PROVIDING THE UC
UNRESTRICTED BASE GROWTH GIVEN
THE L. A. O.'S COMMENT THAT THEY
BELIEVE IT IS A POOR APPROACH TO
BUDGETING FOR OPERATING COST.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
CENTER. SO FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
THIS- THERE'S A COUPLE REASONS-
THE FIRST IS THAT THE STATE HAS
TAKEN THIS APPROACH IN THE PAST
. SAMPLE THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT PROVIDED A 5%
FLEXIBLE BASE AUGMENTATION. I
WAS A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THREE
POINT TWO LAST YEAR WE'RE
PROPOSING A TWO HUNDRED POINT
FIVE VERSION OF THAT THIS YEAR
AS THE- FIRST OF SEVERAL SO IN
OUR VIEW IT'S A CONTINUATION UP
APPROVING PRACTICE THAT THE
STATE HAS USED. AB ALL I WILL
JUST KNOW THAT ON THE
PERSPECTIVE THAT IT'S ARBITRARY
WE JUST DON'T WE DON'T SHARE
THAT PERSPECTIVE FROM THE
STATE'S VIEW THERE'S- THERE'S
AVAILABLE RESOURCES SO WE CAN'T
ALWAYS THINK ABOUT BUDGETS ONE
TO ONE DOWN THE LINE BUT FROM A
UC BUDGETING PERSPECTIVE WE HAVE
WORKED WITH THE UC TO ADDRESS
THEIR NEEDS THAT'S PART OF
NEGOTIATING THE CONTRACT OR THE-
MULTI YEAR COMPACT. AND THEN
ULTIMATELY THE BIGGEST ONE FROM
OUR VIEW THAT I THINK WE HAVE
TYPICALLY HAD A DIFFERENT VIEW
OF THE L. L. IS THAT FLEXIBILITY
IS THE BEST WAY WE BELIEVE FOR
THE UC TO ACHIEVE THE GOALS THAT
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS FOR
THIS THIS TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE BUDGET ACT OR GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ALSO THE MULTI YEAR
COMPACT AND IN GENERAL THAT'S
THAT'S WORKED IN THE PAST WHERE-
NOT A ONE TO ONE. WE DON'T WE'RE
NOT TRYING TO TIE THE HANDS OF
YOU SEE TO SAY. X. WAS WITH WITH
THESE EGGS AMOUNTS BECAUSE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT AS KOBE
DEMONSTRATED THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS THAT ARE SHIPPED AROUND
YEAR TO YEAR. OKAY WITH THE L.
A- LIKE TO RESPOND. SURE SO AS
THE RESTORATION NOTES THIS HAS
BEEN A LONG STANDING UP A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN US AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AND ALSO THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION TO. ON
THE STATE HISTORICALLY HAS
PROVIDED- YOU KNOW BASICALLY
SAYS BASED ON A CERTAIN PERCENT
THAT WAS DECIDED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION SOME YEARS IT WAS
FIVE PERCENT. SOME YEARS IT WAS
FOUR PERCENT- I ACTUALLY WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A FIGURE IN THEIR
AGENDA- ON PAGE- FIVE FIGURE ONE
THAT THAT JUST THAT'S SOME RISE
ALL THE BASE INCREASES. THERE
WAS ONE YEAR WHERE THE STATE DID
. ARE CONNECTED TO SPECIFIC COST
INCREASES THAT WAS IN NINETEEN
TWENTY SO THE STATE HAS DONE
THAT BEFORE THAT THAT SEEM TO
WORK WELL- THE STATED THAT.
UNDER FUNDAMENTAL CONCERN AGAIN
IS THAT THE LEGISLATURE REALLY
HAS VERY LITTLE INFORMATION WHEN
IT TEXAS BASED INCREASE APPROACH
AS TO WHAT SPECIFICALLY
SUPPORTING. AND THIS IS IN PART
BECAUSE THE UNIVERSITY DOESN'T-
YOU KNOW. ALL HER BUDGET PLAN
UNTIL OUT THE AND ACTED. THE
LEGISLATURE REALLY DOESN'T KNOW
WHAT IS GOING FOR COST INCREASES
WHAT IS GOING FOR SALARY
INCREASES- IF THE LEGISLATURE
HAS SPECIFIC PRIORITIES LIKE IT
WANTS TO SUPPORT CERTAIN STUDENT
SUCCESS INITIATIVES THAT HAS.
VERY LITTLE CONFIDENCE JUST.
PROVIDING A BASE INCREASING
THAT'S WHAT THE FUNDING IS BEING
USED FOR. THAT'S WHY WE THINK
TYING IT TO SPECIFIC COST
INCREASES OF A MORE EFFECTIVE
APPROACH- WE CAN HEARD WITH THE
MISTER. THAT THE LEGISLATURE
LEGISLATORS ON THE STATE'S
BUDGET SITUATIONS DIFFERENT
EVERY YEAR IT'S REASONABLE THAT
THE STATE WOULD- YOU KNOW
REVISIT HOW MUCH FUNDING IT HAS
AVAILABLE FOR ON GOING BASE
INCREASES THAT YOU SEE EACH YEAR
. I ACTUALLY THINK THAT'S ONE
REASON WHY WE WOULD CAUTION
AGAINST- COMMITTING IT TOO FAR
IN THE FUTURE TO THE SORT OF
ARBITRARY BASE INCREASES- HAD
THAT STATE TAKEN THAT APPROACH
TWO YEARS AGO- IT WOULD NOT HAVE
INSTEAD OF THE PANDEMIC WOULD
HAVE HAD TO REACT ON THAT PRETTY
QUICKLY- AND- AND REDUCE UC'S
BUDGET. I'M SO WE DO THINK THAT
THE BUDGET SITUATION IS
SOMETHING LEGISLATURE SHOULD
KEEP IN MIND THAT DOESN'T
PRECLUDE THE LEGISLATURE
NONETHELESS FROM UNDERSTANDING
UC'S. COST DRIVERS ARE TRYING
TO. TIE ITS- FUNDING
AUGMENTATIONS TO THE SPECIFIC
COST DRIVERS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- SO JUST SO THAT I AM CLEAR
. RIGHT NOW WITH THE WAY THAT WE
SEE IT IS A IT'S A 5% INCREASE
FOR THE NEXT FIVE YEARS A YEAR
FIVE YEAR PER YEAR. FOR THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS YES THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE PROPOSING THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE PROPOSING AND THE L. A.
ALWAYS HAVING CONCERNS ABOUT
COMMITTING. THAT FUNDING. FOR
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS. I THINK
THE- THE THIS IS US- ARE YOU
PUTTING WORDS IN THE MOUTH OF
FINANCE AND NOW ME PUTTING WORDS
IN THE MOUTH OF THE ALLEY- BUT I
THINK THAT THERE. ARE IT'S NOT
THAT THAT THEY HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH PUTTING THE RESOURCES TO
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST IT'S JUST
THAT THEY BELIEVED THAT A NUMBER
5% EVERY YEAR IS ARBITRARY AND
THAT YOU SHOULD TURN IT TO
SPECIFIC EXPENSES OR NEEDS. AND
CREATE ACCOUNTABILITY AND- ARE
THERE ANY CONCERNS THAT WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO MEET THAT. THAT
COMMITMENT. WELL ACTUALLY LET'S
DIRECT THAT THE A. I. I'M
ACTUALLY HAVING A GREAT TIME
RESPONDING FOR FINANCING THE L.
A. OPENED A I THINK LET'S LET.
OF FINANCE RESPOND TO THAT. SO
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION I DO
APPRECIATE IT- SURE LAYERED- THE
PRE ANSWER NO FROM FINANCES
PERSPECTIVE THE MINISTRATION
CONSIDER THE 5% THE RIGHT. THE
RIGHT AMOUNT BECAUSE WE WERE
VERY CAREFUL ABOUT LOOKING AT
THE OUT YEARS- AND- WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THAT SOMETHING LIKE A COVE
IT IS- YOU KNOW THERE'S ECONOMIC
SHOCKS THAT. CAN RESTRUCTURE
THINGS BUT- THIS IS OUR ATTEMPT
AT GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW AND GIVEN
THE STATE'S AVAILABLE RESOURCES
WE STRUCTURE THE BUDGET IN A WAY
THAT'S NOT JUST LOOKING AT THE
UC RISEN OVERALL FISCAL.
SUSTAINABILITY ARCHITECTURE THIS
ADMINISTRATION'S BEEN VERY LASER
FOCUSED ON. AND SO DOES THIS 5%
FOR US IS WHAT WE SEE AS THE
AVAILABLE RESOURCES- THAT WE
COULD CONTRIBUTE TO THE UC. AND
THAT WE COULD ACHIEVE THE GOALS
THAT WE AGREED UPON WITH THE UC
TOWARDS TOWARDS WORKING ON. IN
THE FIVE YEAR PERIOD AND- GO
AHEAD MR CONTENT TO OTHERS FROM
THE HELLO- I ALSO WANTED JUST A
CLEAR FIVE POINT TO JUST HAVE-
MAKE SURE YOU KNOW AS YOU'RE
WEIGHING YOUR OPTIONS HERE- YOU
KNOW THAT THE PROPOSAL BEFORE
THE LITERAL COMPOSABLE FOR YOU
IS A FIVE PERCENT. INCREASE IN
THE BUDGET YEAR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS ANNOUNCED A COMPACT A MULTI
YEAR CONTRACT THAT WOULD LIKE TO
IMPLEMENT BUT A DOCTOR THE
INCREASE THIS YEAR DOES THAT-
NECESSARILY COMMIT THE
LEGISLATURE TO THOSE INCREASES
IN THE FUTURE. SO EACH YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONTINUE TO
REVISIT THE CONTACT- AND- I JUST
FUNDING ACCORDINGLY SO IT DOES
IT'S NOT LIKE IF YOU WERE JUST
AN INCREASE THIS YEAR YOU'VE
YOU'VE COMMITTED DOWN THE ROAD.
LEGISLATURE STILL HAS SOME.
DISCRETION I THINK OUR POINT IS
JUST WANT TO COST THE
LEGISLATURE AGAINST FOR
COMMITTING TO IT- AGAIN IT'S
GONNA IT'S- POSSIBILITY TO
REVISIT THINGS AND YOU. YEARS AS
- BUDGET CONDITIONS CHANGE AS
COST PRESSURES CHANGE. AND I
THINK THIS IS WHERE I WOULD MAKE
A COMMENT A- IN THAT IS AS I
RECALL BEING RESOURCES SECRETARY
AND- US SITTING IN THE CHAIR-
BASS HAVING THEM ASK ME ABOUT A
HUNDRED. I THINK IT WAS A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
COMMITMENT EVERY YEAR FOR FIVE
YEARS OR FIVE HUNDRED FOR FIRE
PREVENTION AND IT MAY BE
RESPONDING THAT I LOOKED UP AT
THE COMMITTEE AND I ONLY SAW ONE
LEGISLATOR THAT'D BEEN THERE IN
BAD ECONOMIC TIMES. AND THAT
WHEN YOU COMMIT 45% A YEAR OVER
FIVE YEARS. IF WE JUST HAPPEN TO
HAVE SOMETHING THAT WAS EVEN
HALFWAY TOWARD THE GREAT
RECESSION OF TWO THOUSAND NINE
TEN AND ELEVEN IT WOULD SEVERELY
IMPACT THE STATE'S ABILITYTO
MAKE GOOD ON THAT 5% A YEAR AND
I THINK. I'M JUST PUTTING A
FINER POINT ON WHAT DELAY- JUST
SAID BECAUSE IT REALLY IS
SUBJECT TO IT YOU KNOW BEFORE
THE- ECONOMIC DOWNTURN WE WERE
IN THE LARGEST CONTINUOUS PERIOD
OF EXPANSION SINCE WORLD WAR
TWO. HAND PEOPLE FORGOT WHAT
IT'S LIKE TO HAVE THE TROUGHS OF
IT GOING DOWN SO IF THERE'S A
TROUGH IT GOING DOWN IN THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS WILL BE VERY
DIFFICULT TO BEAT UP 5% COMPARED
. BUT OUR- BUT YOU'RE ASKING
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT YOU SEE IF
YOU OF ANOTHER ONE YOU WANT TO
GO TO THAT I THINK YOU'RE I
THINK YOU UNDERSTAND MY POINT OF
YOU KNOW I THINK YOU JUST
ACTUALLY ADDRESS THE CONCERN
THAT I HAVE MOVING FORWARD YOU
KNOW MAKING A COMMITMENT FIVE
YEARS ON THE LINE- ON A GOOD
YEAR. AS WE HAVE TO. THIS YEAR.
JUST MAKES ME A BIT NERVOUS- AND
I'VE AND I ACTUALLY APPRECIATE
THE COMMENT THAT WE SHOULD- MAKE
IT A PRIORITY TO HAVE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS THE ABILITY TO
EVALUATE OR REEVALUATE EVERY
SINGLE YEAR- IN GOING BACK TO
THE- THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS A COMMENT THAT- WITH REGARDS
TO. IT HAS BEEN DONE IN THE PAST
THAT IT HAS WORKED AND THAT'S
WHAT SHOULD BE DONE I'M JUST
ALWAYS VERY CURIOUS ABOUT. I
DON'T REALLY BUY INTO THAT
MINDSET JUST BECAUSE WITH THAT
IN THE PAST YOU KNOW WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO DO IT I. I LOOK AT
ALL OF YOUR FEEDBACK IN ALL OF
YOUR COMMENTS AND I DO. NOT TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION THE L. A.
O.'S COMMENT THAT- THEY LIKE TO
HAVE IT AB PRIORITY BASED
APPROACH TO THE FINANCE SO-
DEPARTMENT FINEST I DISAGREE ON
THAT AND JUST BECAUSE IT OUT OF
THE PAST AS I MEAN. YOU KNOW IF
THE BEST PLAYER OF THE ULTIMATE
WEIGHT TO DO IT IN THE FUTURE-
BUT I DO BUT I DO RESPECT BOTH.
PERSPECTIVE I JUST WANT TO SEE.
SAID THIS RESPECTFULLY-
DISAGREE. I MEAN RESPECTFULLY.
DISAGREE THAT'S- RESEARCH
DISAGREE ON THAT IN BUT- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS AND SENATOR MAN LIFE
TWO QUESTIONS THAT WERE IN THIS
CATEGORY AND I'M GOING TO ASK
THEM SEPARATELY AND I THINK SOME
OF THE- OF THE ITEMS HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED ALREADY YOU CAN FEEL
FREE TO REFER YOURSELF TO
PREVIOUS ANSWER. AND JUST ADD.
BUT THE FIRST ONE IS A QUESTION
FOR ANY WROTE THIS IN THE THIRD
PERSON SO I'M KIND OF LIKING IT
ON. ME HE SAYS HE IS CONCERNED
ABOUT THE PROPOSED TUITION
INCREASES THE BIG QUESTION THAT
HE HAS FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. IS HOW THEY ARE
WORKING TO CREATE A DEBT FREE
COLLEGE EXPERIENCE FOR THEIR
STUDENTS WHEN AT THE SAME TIME
THEY ARE PLANNING TO OCEAN
INCREASES AND SO ALL PUT THAT TO
THE- UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTATIVE. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION. THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA REGENTS VOTED TO TAKE
45% OF ALL OF OUR TUITION
INCREASES AND PUT THEM TOWARD
FINANCIAL AID FOR OUR LOWEST
INCOME STUDENTS SO BECAUSE OF
THIS RETURN TO AID- WITH OUR
PRIOR RETURN TRADE POLICIES
WHILE THE UNIVERSITY IS ABLE TO
OFFER SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNTS OF
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR POOR
STUDENTS TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT
THEY DON'T SUFFER ADVERSE
IMPACTS FROM ANY TUITION
INCREASE. IN FACT THIRTY THREE
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS OF
THE- TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
COHORT BASED TUITION INCREASE
WILL GO TO FINANCIAL AID FOR OUR
LOWEST INCOME STUDENTS. THANK
YOU RIGHT THAT AND THEN HIS
SECOND QUESTION IS A GENERALLY
HE'S SUPPORTIVE OF BASE
INCREASES BUT WANTS TO ENSURE
THAT BASE SPENDING GOES TOWARD
SUPPORTING STUDENTS AND
IMPROVING OUTCOMES FOR EXAMPLE
HOW DOES THIS BASE INCREASE
AFFECT ITS ABILITY TO HIRE STAFF
TO OFFER MORE COURSE OPERATE
OFFERINGS TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
ADDITIONAL STUDENTS PARTICULARLY
REDUCING THE TIME 2 DEGREES AND
ALL HOME I THINK OF DIRECT THAT
TO YOU SEE IF ANYBODY ELSE
WISHES TO COMMENT THAT CAN.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
SENATOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA TAKES THE- BASED
BUDGET INCREASES PROVIDED BY THE
STATE. AND WE POVIDED TO OUR
CAMPUSES ON A PER STUDENT
FORMULA THAT'S THE REPRINTING
FORMULA WE DISCUSSED EARLIER.
THE CHANCELLOR'S HAVE THE
ABILITY AND THE FLEXIBILITY TO
INVEST THOSE FUNDS ARE ON THEIR
CAMPUS TO THE STUDENT SERVICES
AND INSTRUCTIONAL PURPOSES THAT
THEY MOST NEED TO FIND. THAT'S
PART OF THE REASON- WE WANT SOME
FLEXIBILITY IN THAT BASE BUDGET
SO THAT WE CAN ALLOW OUR
CHANCELLORS TO CHOOSE WHICH
TYPES OF SERVICES THAT THEY WANT
TO FIND ON THEIR CAMPUS THE MOST
. MUCH OF THIS FUNDING WILL GO
TOWARD BASE BUDGET COST
INCREASES ON THE CAMPUSES RATHER
THAN HIRING NEW STAFF OR SAY.
THE 5% WILL GO TO SUPPORT
EXISTING OPERATIONS AND SOME
ENHANCEMENTS AND PROVIDING
ADVISING AND OTHER ACTIVITIES TO
TRY TO CLOSE THOSE GRADUATION
GAPS. MUCH OF THE HIRING THAT
WILL BE DONE WILL BE WITH THE
NEW ENROLLMENT FUNDING THAT THE
GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING FOR THE
UNIVERSITY THAT WILL DISCUSS AS
PART THE NEXT ITEM. NINETY EIGHT
MILLION THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
LET ME JUST ASK. AS WE GET READY
TO MOVE TO THE NEXT ITEM WAS OR
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THE L. A.
OVER FINANCE WISHED TO ADD TO
THE- THOSE TWO QUESTIONS. IF I
MADE SURE JUST OUT OF A POINT
UNDERLINED WITH THE UC OFFERED
ON A SENATOR MEN'S QUESTION
ABOUT BASING CREASES. AND
STUDENT SUCCESS. OUR FROM OUR
VIEW THE COMPACT HAS BEEN
DESIGNED IN A WAY WE'VE AGREED
WITH THE UC ON. OUT FAIRLY
AMBITIOUS GOALS TO IMPROVE
GRADUATION RATES FOR EXAMPLE IN
OTHER OUTCOMES THAT WILL
DIRECTLY. BENEFIT STUDENTS IN
TERMS OF WHAT IT COSTS TO GO TO
COLLEGE HOW QUICKLY YOU CAN GET
A DEGREE. ETCETERA AND SO THE
BASING CREASES. IN OUR VIEW HAVE
BEEN DESIGNED IN A WAY THAT'S
GOING TO IMPROVE STUDENT
OUTCOMES. THANK YOU THIS ELIO
ANY. LAST WORDS BEFORE WE MOVE
ON- WHAT WE'RE HAPPY TO WITH-
STAFF IS NEEDED- THE SENATE ANY
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE A
SPECIFIC PRIORITIES THEY WANT TO
ENSURE FUND BUDGET. YOU KNOW
GENERALLY THE MOST DIRECT WAY
THE LEGISLATURE CAN ENSURE FUNDS
ARE SPENT ACCORDING TO ITS
PRIORITIES IS TO SPECIFY THEM
THE BUDGET- SOMETIMES A
LEGISLATURE DOES GIVE SOME
FLEXIBILITY FOR EXAMPLE WHEN
MEET YOU'LL HEAR THE NEXT ITEM-
AND BOTTOM LINE GROWTH IN A
LEGISLATURE IN THE PAST HAS
GIVEN FUNDS FOR ROMAN GROWTH.
OTHERS FUNDS ARE INTENDED TO
COVER MORE FACULTY- YOU KNOW
HIRE OTHER HIGHER COSTS THE
STUDY ASSOCIATED WITH LOAN
GROWTH. CAMPUSES AREN'T REQUIRED
TO SPEND IT ON THOSE EXACT
ACTIVITIES THEY THEY CAN ARE
PRIORITIZE A LITTLE BIT AS THE
SCENE AS THEY SEE FIT- BUT
THAT'S WHAT IT IS IF THERE ARE
SPECIFIC PRIORITIES USUALLY THE
WAY TO DO THIS. BY THE BUDGET.
OKAY YOU VERY MUCH N. THANK
EVERYBODY. ON THAT PANEL THE-
FOR WORK WITH US THE QUESTIONS
AND WE'LL GO TO MOVE TO ISSUE TO
IS RESIDENT AND NONRESIDENT
ENROLLMENT WHICH WE HAVE STARTED
TO TALK ABOUT. AN AMAZINGLY IT'S
EXACTLY THE SAME PANEL IN
EXACTLY THE SAME QUARTER. SO ARE
WE WILL START WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE GO TO THE
L. A. O. AND THEN TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. MISTER
RUTTLEDGE WELCOME BACK TO THE
COMPANY. THANKS SO MUCH CHAIR.
SO ON UNDER ROMAN- JUST BRIEFLY
RESTATE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE INCLUDES SIXTY SEVEN POINT
EIGHT MILLION. ONGOING THAT
WOULD SUPPORT SIXTY TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY. RESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATE SPOTS. AN INCREASE
OF UP SIXTY TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY- THAT IS FROM THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT THERE IS
AN AGREEMENT. MADE THAT THAT
WOULD BE THE NUMBER FOR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AND IN ADDITION
TO THOSE THERE'S ALSO THIRTY ONE
MILLION. FOR YOUR SUPPORT-
ESSENTIAL THE- SHIFTING OF
COMPOSITION WHERE THERE'S A
DECREASING PROPORTION OF NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS AND A
CORRESPONDING INCREASE IN
RESIDENTS STUDENTS. IN THE
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. BUDGET
YEAR AND SO WE'VE WE'RE
PROPOSING. FUNDING FOR- THE
TOTAL IS OVER. SEVENTY ONE
HUNDRED NEW UNDERGRADUATES. OKAY
THANK YOU LMAO. SO THIS ITEM IS
A BIT MORE COMPLICATED AND-
PASSING MOMENT ISSUES YOU REALLY
HAVE TO- ITEMS EMBEDDED IN THIS
ISSUE OTHER FIRST IS
IMPLEMENTING EXPECTATIONS THAT
WERE SET IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
ABOUT ENROLLMENT GROWTH IN THE
BUDGET YEAR TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. AND THE SECOND ISSUE IS
LOOKING AHEAD INTO THE FUTURE
FOR A MOMENT SO I'LL TOUCH ON
EACH ISSUE SEPARATELY. OUR FIRST
ON THE FIRST ISSUE IN TERMS OF
IMPLEMENTING PAST AGREEMENTS
JUST WANT TO REITERATE- WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION INTRODUCED THE
MINISTRATION IS PROPOSING A
TOTAL INCREASE OF NINETY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR A TOTAL
RESIDENT UNDERGRADUATE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH OF SEVEN
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED THIRTY TWO
STUDENTS THAT INCLUDE SOME-
BASED WOMAN GROWTH THAT WAS
EXPECTED A MASTER'S BUDGET. PLUS
ADDITIONAL GROWTH ASSOCIATED
WITH THE NON RESIDENT
REPLACEMENT PLAN BECAUSE OF THAT
NON RESIDENT REPLACEMENT
COMPONENT THAT TOTAL COST IS A
LITTLE BIT HIGHER THAN IT
NORMALLY WOULD BE IF THERE'S
JUST A MOMENT REST. I DON'T WE
WANT TO THE COMMITTEES THAT THAT
THERE'S A BIT OF A DISCONNECT
BETWEEN WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
IS PROPOSING AND WHAT THE
UNIVERSITY IS PLANNING. THAT'S
BECAUSE YOU'LL HEAR FROM YOU SEE
IN A MINUTE- YOU SEE IS PLANNING
TO GROW IN A RESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATE BERMAN AROUND. TWO
THOUSAND STUDENTS IN THE BUDGET
YEAR AND THAT'S INCLUSIVE OF THE
GROWTH ASSOCIATED WITH THE NON
RESIDENT REDUCTION PLANS.
ACCORDING TO YOU SEE I WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE THE REMAINING FUNDS
FOR THEIR FOR THEIR ADDITIONAL
GROWTH AND APPLY IT TOWARDS OVER
TARGET GROSS THAT IT EXPERIENCED
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. SH
AND GIVEN THAT THE UNIVERSITY
HAS TO RESPECT THOSE
EXPECTATIONS FOR ITS FALL
EMISSIONS PLANNING THAT THAT IS
VERY LIKELY THE MOMENT LEVEL
THAT WILL OF A ROUGHLYOCCUR AT
THE UNIVERSITY. SO THE ISSUE
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE IS REALLY
HOW TO RESPOND. TO THIS
DISCONNECT. ARE WE THINK A GOOD
STARTING POINT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD BE TO- START
WITH UC'S PLANNED TWO THOUSAND
STUDENT GROWTH. THAT WOULD COST
ABOUT FORTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS SO BASED ON THE MARGINAL
COST RATE AND INCLUDING THAT
ADDITIONAL COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE NON RESIDENT REDUCTION PLAN
. THE LEGISLATURE PROVIDE MORE
THAN THAT FORTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR EXAMPLE COULD IT
COULD PROVIDE UP TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED LEVEL NINETY
NINE MILLION DOLLARS. DOING SO
WOULD- PROVIDED FUNDING
ESSENTIALLY FOR THAT OVER TARGET
GROWTH. AND WOULD PROVIDE
GENERAL FUNDING FOR YOU SEE THAT
MORE COURSES. AN INCREASE JUST
OVERALL A BASE. SUPPORT PER
STUDENT AT UC. PAST HASN'T
PROVIDED FUNDING OVER TARGET
ROSE IN THE PREVIOUS YEAR.
OMINOUS SOMETHING A LOT WANNA BE
ABLE TO ABOUT JUST THAT- IT
DOESN'T INCENTIVE FOR. TO NOT
FOLLOWS STATE- AND MOMENT TARGET. THERE IS A ROW TO MAYBE AN
EXTRA THIS YEAR THAT'S- YOU
MIGHT RECALL TO TWENTY ONE WAS
DURING PANDEMIC. AND YOU SEE DID
- AND HIGH LEVELS OF A MOMENT TO
ME PART DURING THE SUMMER- AND
GIVEN ALL THAT IN. AROUND A
MOMENT DURING THE PANDEMIC THE
LET'S. MY BE INTERESTED IN IN
SUPPORTING OVER TARGET MOMENTS
THIS CASE IT IT'S REALLY FALLS
ON THE LARGEST- WOULD LIKE DO
THIS CASE. AS TO THE SECOND IS-
IT'S- ABOUT AND WOMAN IN. YEARS
WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE.
THE STATE'S FIRST PRACTICE
YESTERDAY A WOMAN TARGET FOR THE
- BUDGET YEAR PLUS ONE THAT'S-
TWENTY. TWENTY THREE TO FOUR-
THIS TAKING THE CIPRO BECAUSE-
YOU SEE YOUR MAKES FALL IT- THIS
DECISION. BEFORE THE LETTER CAN
ENACT THE FINAL BY IN JUNE. THAT
MEANS THERE WAY THE LEGISLATURE
INFLUENCE MISSION. JUST TO SET A
TARGET FOR THE FALL YEAR THERE
BY GIVE YOU SEE TO PLAN FOR THAT
IT MAKES FALL MISSION. NO WE
DON'T HAVE ANY. RECOMMENDATION
TO THE- LEVEL THAT THE LOWER. I
SHOULD SET A MOMENT BUT WE DO
OUR SOME FAQ. YOU CAN FIRST ON
THE BOTTOM OF ELEVEN. YOU KNOW
THE ONE HAND IT. OF IT WHEN WE
LOOK AT SOME OF THE PROJECTIONS
FOR STATE DEMOGRAPHICS THERE
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE- SERVER HUGE
LEVEL OF GROWTH ANTICIPATED. FOR
YOU KNOW NORMAN DEMAND HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES ARE PROJECTED
TO RISE VERY SLIGHTLY. AND THEN-
THREE TO CULTURAL BUT IT'S
ACTUALLY- EXPECTED TO BE DOWN.
THAT COULD INFLUENCE THAT
TRANSFER WILL DEMAND IN THE
COMING YEARS. ON THE OTHER HAND
AS THE AS YOU MAY KNOW THE-
UNIVERSITY HAS A PRETTY LARGE
POOL OF STUDENTS THAT IT-
REFERS- IT BECAUSE IT SEEMS
COULD BE ADMITTED TO THE FIRST
CHOICE CAMPUS- STUDENTS ARE CHEN
. FOR TO THE RECESSION ORDER-
WORK RIVERSIDE OR WORSE. AND
VERY FEW THE STUDENTS END UP.
EXCEPT THEIR IMAGE OFFER. SO
INCREASING AND- COULD ALLOW UNIT
. TO RID OUR ALL POLL. AT A
COMEDY MORE SEE TO THEIR FOR
CHOICE CAN. REGARDLESS OF THE
EXACT HARD YOU SAID WE WELCOME
THAT INSTEAD OF UP FOR GROWTH.
TARGET SAID HELLO TARGETS IT'S
AN EXTRA. GROW WITH THOUSANDS
OVER PRETTY YEAR RIGHT SAY. AND
YOU KNOW. YOU KNOW SOME TWO
HUNDRED OR WHATEVER THE LEVEL IN
IN THIS YEAR. WE GOT A PRO- HAS
THE BEEN OF. REALLY CLEAR WHAT
THAT THE IS MORE THAN FOUR SO
THAT WHEN THE UNIT IS HAS A
MOMENT PLAN LARGEST CAN. HOLD
ACCOUNTABLE TO- WHAT ITS
EXPECTATIONS FOR. WITHOUT IT WE
HAVE TO ANSWER ANY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BUT NOW WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO UC. THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IS COMMITTED TO
GROWING ACCESS FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS WE RECOGNIZE THAT
ECONOMIC SECURITY AND
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY ARE
CONNECTED AND THAT ACCESS TO THE
UNIVERSITY. OF CALIFORNIA WILL
GIVE OUR FUTURE STUDENTS THE
CHANCE TO PURSUE THEIR DREAMS.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSED A
SIXTY SEVEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
ONGOING FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA TO INCREASE
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATE
ENROLLMENT BY SIX THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY STUDENTS BY
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
THESE FUNDS ARE IN ADDITION TO
THE BASE BUDGET INCREASE WE'VE
PREVIOUSLY DISCUSSED. HERE SEE
APPRECIATES THIS PROPOSED
INVESTMENTS IN OUR STUDENTS AND
WE REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THESE FUNDS. WE DO HAVE A
REQUEST ON HOW THIS PROPOSED
ENROLLMENT GROWTH OF SIX
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
STUDENTS WOULD BE MEASURED. THE
LAST TIME THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDED TO UNIVERSITY WITH
ENROLLMENT GROWTH FUNDS WHAT'S
IN THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. AT THAT TIME YOU
FUNDED FOUR THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED SIXTY STUDENTS OVER TWO
YEARS AT OUR CAMPUSES. THE
UNIVERSITY EXCEEDED THIS TARGET
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE
ARE REQUESTING THAT YOU COUNT
ALL THE STUDENTS ABOUT THE
FUNDED ENROLLMENT TARGET SET IN
THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. AS ENROLLMENT TOWARDS
THE GOAL OF SIX THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY STUDENTS. THE
UNIVERSITY WANTS TO PROVIDE ALL
OUR STUDENTS WITH EQUAL
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE. AND
FUNDING THE STUDENTS WILL ALLOW
US TO HIRE FACULTY TO TEACH
COURSES AND THE STAFF TO PROVIDE
ACADEMIC SERVICES THAT THE
STUDENTS. COMING TO STUDENTS
ENROLLED ABOVE THE TARGETED
ENROLLMENT SET IN THE BUDGET ACT
OF TWENTY NINETEEN. WOULD MEAN
THAT THE CAMPUSES WOULD ENROLL
AN ADDITIONAL TWELVE HUNDRED NEW
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATES. IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE. IN
ADDITION TO THE SAN ROMAN GROWTH
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES UP THIRTY
ONE MILLION I'M GOING FOR THE
UNIVERSITY TO REPLACE NINE
HUNDRED AND TO NONRESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS WITH
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT STUDENTS FOR
FALL TWENTY TWENTY TWO. ON THE
UC BERKELEY UCLA AND UC SAN
DIEGO CAMPUS AS- THE CAMPUSES
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THEIR FALL
TWENTY TWO ENROLLMENT PLANS AND
ALL THREE CAMPUSES INTEND TO
REPLACE THREE HUNDRED
NONRESIDENT STUDENTS. WITH
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATES THE
REACH THIS NINE HUNDRED AND TWO
STUDENT REPLACEMENT GOAL.
RECEIVING THE FUNDING FOR THE
NON RESIDENT REPLACEMENT IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE CAMPUSES RELY
ON THESE FUNDS FOR MANY ASPECTS
OF THE CAMPUS OPERATIONS. FROM
HIRING FACULTY TO TEACH MORE
COURSES THE STUDENT SERVICES TO
MAINTAINING THE CAMPUS
FACILITIES. CURRENTLY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RECEIVED OVER 12% OF CAMPUS CORE
FUNDS FROM NONRESIDENT
SUPPLEMENTAL TUITION PAID BY NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS. THE NEW
ENROLLMENT GROWTH AND NON
RESIDENTS REPLACEMENT PLAN MEANS
THAT WITH THE CURRENT FUNDING
PROVIDED UC CAMPUSES WILL ADD
ANOTHER TWO THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATES. FOR
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE. FOR FALL
TWENTY ONE UNIVERSITY RECEIVED
THEIR LARGEST NUMBER OF
UNDERGRADUATE APPLICATIONS IN
OUR HISTORY AND ADMITTED OUR
MOST DIVERSE FRESHMAN CLASS EVER
THE UNIVERSITY ALSO ENROLLED
MORE LAST NEXT TO DANCE AND FALL
TWENTY ONE THAN EVER BEFORE AND
MORE AFRICAN AMERICAN GRADUATE
STUDENTS THAN IN ANY PREVIOUS
YEAR. TO CONTINUE THE SUCCESS
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES TO SUPPORT
UNIVERSITY IN FUTURE YEARS WITH
1% ANNUAL ENROLLMENT GROSS. THIS
ENROLLMENT GROWTH WOULD BE
FUNDED THROUGH THE 5% ANNUAL
BASE BUDGET INCREASES SUPPORT
FOR THOSE AND ADDITIONAL
ENROLLMENT IS VITAL TO PROVIDING
INCREASED ACCESS AND OPPORTUNITY
FOR FUTURE YOU SEE STUDENTS. THE
1% GROWTH WOULD TRANSLATE TO
ROUGHLY TWO THOUSAND NEW
CALIFORNIA UNDERGRADUATES
ANNUALLY. AND AN ANNUAL STATE
SUPPORT COST OF ROUGHLY. TWENTY
THREE TO TWENTY FIVE MILLION AS
ENROLLMENT GROWS. N ADDITION
THE GOVERNOR'S MULTI YEAR BUDGET
PROPOSED SOUL INCLUDES
ENROLLMENT OF TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED NEW GRADUATE STUDENTS
BETWEEN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. AND TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN WITH THE FUNDING COMING
FROM THE PROPOSED 5% BASED
BUDGET INCREASE. PRESIDENT DRAKE
WANTS TO INCREASED UNIVERSITY IS
A ROMAN BY TWENTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS BY TWENTY THIRTY.
INCLUDED IN THIS PROPOSED GROSS
ARE SIXTEEN THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATES AND FOUR THOUSAND
GRADUATE STUDENTS. THE
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS INCLUDE
THE REPLACEMENT OF NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS FOR CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET WILL ALLOW US TO
MAKE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
TOWARDS THIS GOAL. SOME OF THE
PROPOSED NEW ENROLLMENT WILL BE
ACCOMMODATED THROUGH INCREASED
ONLINE LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES BY
INCREASING GRADUATION RATES TO
ALLOW FOR FASTER THROUGHPUT OF
STUDENTS. AND INCREASED
UTILIZATION OF SUMMER SESSIONS
IN CLOSING WE REQUEST YOU
SUPPORT THE FUNDING IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BE USED TO
ENROLLMENT. BUT CHANGE THE
MEASUREMENT FOR ROMAN GROWTH TO
BE FROM THE FUNDED LEVEL AND THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY NINETEEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
QUESTIONS AND- BEFORE WE GET TO
A OF A FEW QUESTIONS BEFORE WE
GET TOO FAR AWAY FROM THOSE
PRESENTATIONS. I WAS GONNA ASK
THE L. A. O. TO COMMENT. ON WHAT
THE UNIVERSITY JUST SAID ABOUT
HOW TO COUNT ENROLLMENT AND WHAT
YOUR OPINION IS ABOUT THE- AND
YOU MIGHT EVEN JUST EXPLAIN.
YOUR UNDERLYING FACTUAL LOOK AT
IT AS WELL SO THAT IT'S JUST
CLEAR TO US WHAT THE CHOICES. I
SURE SO THE- THE- WHAT. LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET ACT SENATE
EXPECTATION THAT YOU SEE GROW
ENROLLMENT BY SIX THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY STUDENTS. AND IT
WAS OVER THE LEVEL IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND THE
LANGUAGE THERE BUT DIDN'T
SPECIFY THAT IT WAS OVER A
FUNDED BASELINE OR IF IT
ASSEMBLY CATION IT WAS OVER SORT
OF THE ACTUAL LEVEL OF
INVOLVEMENT IN THAT YEAR. UC'S
TELLING YOU THAT- AND MOMENT IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE CAME IN
ABOVE WHAT WAS BUT THEY HAD
EXPECTED AND A LOT OF THAT WAS
DRIVEN BY THE PANDEMIC- IN
DURING THE PANDEMIC THERE IS A
HUGE GROWTH IN SUMMER ROMANCE
AND THAT APPEARS TO HAVE BEEN
DRIVEN BY- YOU KNOW THE
AVAILABILITY OF ONLINE COURSES
DURING THE SUMMER OR PERHAPS
LIMITED EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
DURING THE SUMMER. AND THAT AND
THAT GROWTH HAS PERSISTED INTO
THE CURRENT YEAR TOO SO IT'S NOT
LIKE A MOMENT WHEN DOWN THE
FOLLOWING YEAR. THE UNIVERSITY
BUT LET ME DO IT LET ME TRY TO
SIMPLIFY THIS AND SEE IF WE CAN
GET A TO AN ELEVATOR SPEECH IT
IS WHAT REALLY HAPPENS IS THAT
UC'S INTERPRETING WHAT THE
BASELINE WAS A VOTE FOR THE
SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED OR WHATEVER
THAT IT ADDITIONAL FUNDED GROWTH
A DIFFERENT THAN WHAT MIGHT HAVE
BEEN OR INTENT OR WHAT WE MIGHT
HAVE THOUGHT WHEN WE DID IT- IT
IS IT THAT. WE WERE REALLY
LOOKING FOR SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED
OVER THE CURRENT GROWTH AND DAY
ADMITTED MMHM WELL IS THERE A
MOMENT WAS HIGHER THAN I THOUGHT
IT WAS GOING TO BE WHEN THEY DID
THE ADMITTED TO THEY'RE DOING IT
FROM THE HIGHER ENROLLMENT THAT
THEY- HAD I'M TRYING TO YEAH I
THINK I THINK THAT'S A I THINK
THAT'S A FAIR WAY OF STAYING AT
DATE OF THE BUDGET ACT SEEMS TO
HAVE BEEN WRITTEN WHERE IT WAS.
DEGREE WOULD HAVE BEEN OVER ACT
KNOWN. BUT YOU SEE LIKE. TO-
COUNT TOWARD WHAT THE AS STAR
SOURCE OF THERE BUT LEVEL OF
MOMENT WHICH WAS. HELLO BECAUSE
OF CERTAIN PASSED EXPECT. AND
BUT ACTS OCCURRED HAVING MUCH
PUTTING INTO MOUTHS TODAY O
WHAT I THE PRETTY. THAT YOU
RECORDS. WOULD BE IS TO IT THIS
YEAR WE SPENT. WHAT IN ROME MAIN
OF THAN. WHY IN ROME MEANS AND
HOWEVER WE ADOPT OUR ACTIONS.
YEAH THAT'S CORRECT WE RECOMMEND
INSTEAD OF- THE WAY WE ARE
PHRASE IT IS INSTEAD OF SETTING
UP A GROWTH TARGET TO SAYING.
SIX THOUSAND STUDENTS OVER A
PREVIOUS YEAR YOU SAY WE WANT.
WE WANT YOU SEE WHAT WE EXPECT
TO SEE TO A ROLL. TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND OR HOW MANY. HOW
MANY- WHAT LEVEL STUDENTS SAID
YEAH- THE STATE WOULD LIKE TO
ENROLL WE THINK THAT WOULD
CLARIFY THE ACTUAL BASS LINE AND
THEN THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
STUDENTS THAT THE LEGISLATURE'S
EXPECTING. OUR I JUST AS A
COMMENT I THINK THAT'S GOOD
ADVICE. BUT I ALSO WOULD SAY
THAT. THAT'S ALL HE ONLY THIS
THE UPPER THAT. ON THIS. I GET
THE FOR TO WORK AT ALL FOR OF
YOU. IT APPEARED THAT THE DA. OF
OR A JOY THE FIRST PART OF YOUR-
SO LET ME GIVE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PUT WORDS WITH.
THEIR PERCEIVED ENJOYMENT YEAH.
THANK YOU CHAIR I'LL JUST I'LL
JUST ECHO THAT THAT. JUST TIE
EVERYTHING TOGETHER THAT'S BEEN
SADDENED THAT THIS IS A COMPLEX
ISSUE ENROLLMENT FOR TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE FOR YOU SEE. THIS
ACTUALLY WHAT HAPPENED IS THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT.
WAS THERE WAS INTENSE SET UP.
WHERE THE CIRCUMSTANCES HAVE
ACTUALLY. ARE LESS CLEAR THEY
WERE NOT CLEAR AT THAT TIME AND
NOW WE KNOW THAT THE KOBE YEAR
YEAH ACADEMIC YEAR. I HAD A
DRAMATIC SPIKE FOR UC SO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S POSITION IS WE
NEGOTIATED THE CALM. THINKING
THAT. THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT WE'RE GONNA PROPOSED
FULLY FUNDING AT THE SIXTY TWO
THIRTY WOULD MATERIALIZE IN THIS
UPCOMING BUDGET YEAR. AS NEW
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT.
HOWEVER WE ALL SAY THAT WE ARE.
OPEN TO CONSIDERING IT GOING
FORWARD WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
YOU SEE BECAUSE WE'RE
RECOGNIZING IT'S A COMPLEX ISSUE
. THEN OUR EVEN OUR WANT TO MOVE
ON TO ANOTHER QUESTION LET ME
MAKE A COMMENT WHICH IS I REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS DISCUSSION AND I
THINK AS WE MOVE TOWARD THE MAY
REVISE WE WOULD LIKE TO SEEK
CLARITY. IN OUR HOW WE
DESIGNATE- OTHER. THAN ROMAN AND
I KNOW THAT THAT WE USUALLY.
LIKE TO MAXIMIZE THE FUNDING AND
SO I'M SURE WE WOULD LOVE TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY WHAT WE THOUGHT
OUR INTENT WAS IS LIFT WITH BUT
I ACCEPT THE FACT THAT THERE'S
COMPLEXITY TO THIS. AND I THINK
WE SHOULD JUST HAVE
CONVERSATIONS GOING FORWARD AND
I DON'T FEEL READY TO. EXCEPT
THE WHAT HAPPENED. I THINK WE
JUST HAVE TO LOOK AT IT AND HAVE
CONVERSATIONS OVER THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS. THEN LET ME- ASK A FEW
QUESTIONS. AND ONE IS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. IT WAS
MENTIONED I THINK IN YOUR
COMMENTS THAT YOU WORK TO KEEP
UP WITH THE F. ACADEMIC
INFRASTRUCTURE I KNOW I TALK TO
PEOPLE ON SOME CAMPUSES THAT
DON'T FEEL LIKE THAT IS
HAPPENING SO HOW DO YOU ENSURE.
THAT YOU ADD THE ADDITIONAL AND
ROMAN AND THAT THERE IS A
CORRESPONDING INCREASE OF
ACADEMIC INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS
THE NEED FOR WHICH IS CREATED BY
THE ADDITIONAL MOMENT HOW DO YOU
MAKE SURE THAT HAPPENS. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION SENATOR OUR
CAMPUSES HAVE LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT PLANS WHICH SET
GUIDANCE FOR HOW THE CAMPUS
SHOULD- DEVELOP INFRASTRUCTURE
TO MATCH NEW STUDENT GROSS. OR
TO GUIDE NEW STUDENT GROWTH- IN
ADDITION THE REGENTS APPROVE A
FIVE YEAR INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN
ANNUALLY. THAT SPECIFIES THE
PROJECTS OF WE WOULD LIKE TO ASK
THE SYSTEM CONSTRUCT NEXT- IN
TERMS OF ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTING
THESE PROJECTS THE UNIVERSITY
HAS NOT HAD A GENERAL OBLIGATION
BOND SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND SIX.
WE HAVE BEEN USING OUR OWN
INTERNAL FINANCING MECHANISMS TO
FIND NEW PROJECT CONSTRUCTION-
BUT WHAT THIS MEANS IS THAT WE
CAN ONLY FIND A FEW PROJECTS
ANNUALLY. SO THE THIRD THE
PROGRESS IN DEVELOPING NEW
BUILDINGS ON CAMPUSES IS SLOW
BECAUSE WE ARE LIMITED IN HOW
MUCH FINANCING WE HAVE ACCESS
TO- WE WILL BE PROVIDING THE
LEGISLATURE WITH ADDITIONAL
CAPITAL OUTLAY REQUESTS. AND WE
ALSO HAVE THE REGION'S FIVE YEAR
PLAN IF YOU WANT TO GO THROUGH
IT AND SELECT SOME PROJECTS THAT
SEEM. LIKE SOMETHING THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO FIND-
BUT OUR FOR OUR REQUEST IS- THAT
WE ARE GOING TO BE PROVIDING
VERY SOON IS FOR ONE POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE NEW INFRASTRUCTURE
SEISMIC RENOVATION OF BUILDINGS
AND SOME NEW ACADEMIC SPACE. ARM
I JUST HAVE TO COMMENT ON TO AT
THE END IT'S BECAUSE YOU WERE
BASICALLY PUTTING IT BACK ON US
AND OF COURSE I SUPPORT THE
BUILDINGS ARE SUPPORTED BOND.
AND EVERYTHING BUT- WHEN WE'RE
DISCUSSING INCREASED ENROLLMENTS
AND WHEN YOUR LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT PLANS ARE PUT
FORWARD IT SAYS STUDENTS ARE
ACCEPTED AND THEN IT'S LIKE WELL
IT'S ON US TO HAVE THE
FACILITIES. HE IS THE STUDENTS
WERE WERE OUR ACCEPTED AND SO IT
SEEMS LIKE IT'S THE IT'S THE
PROBLEM WITH THE LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT PLANS THERE WAS A
HUGE DISAGREEMENT OVER THE ONE
IN SANTA CRUZ WHICH IS MY HOME
CAMPUS. AND IT WAS A
DISAGREEMENT OVER THE FAX. AND
SOME OF THE ADVOCATES CONTENDED
THAT A 100% OF THE ENROLLMENT
WAS ADMITTED AND THAT 7% OF THE
NON ENROLLMENT COMMITMENTS WERE
MADE THE UNIVERSITY DISAGREE
STRENUOUSLY AND SAYS IT WAS A
100% OF THE- OF THE ENROLLMENT
AND IT WAS CLOSE TO A 100% OF
THE FACILITIES CAME WITH IT. BUT
IT'S WHY THE LEGISLATURE IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE LAST BOND. ADOPTED LANGUAGE
THAT SAID. HE WOULD NOT BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE NEXT BUILDING
IN A BOND UNTIL YOU MITIGATED
THE IMPACTS FROM THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE PREVIOUS
BONTA BECAUSE FREQUENTLY THE
UNIVERSITY WOULD ASK FOR THE
COST OF THE BUILDING AND SO WE
DON'T HAVE THE MONEY FOR THE-
FOR THE MITIGATION. AND I THINK
THE SAME THING APPLIES HERE AND
I THOUGHT THE SOLUTION. TO THE
CONTENTIOUS LRCP IN SANTA CRUZ
LONG RANGE DEVELOPMENT PAN. WAS
THAT IT'S FINE TO PROJECT-
SIXTEEN THOUSAND MORE STUDENTS
OVER TWENTY YEARS OR WHATEVER IT
WAS. BUT DID YOU WOULD NOT
ADVANCE TO DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
ENROLLMENT VENTO YOU COMMITTED
TO ADVANCE TO DIFFERENT ROMANCE
OF THE ACADEMIC AND PHYSICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN A PHASE FOR
THAT ENROLLMENT GOING. THAT JUST
DOESN'T SEEM RIGHT TO SAY WELL
YOU GUYS DIDN'T FUNDED SO WE'RE
JUST GONNA TAKE TO STUDENTS AND
WE WON'T HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
TO DO IT THERE HAS TO BE A
BETTER WAY. OF DOING IT AND I
KNOW. EVEN THOUGH IT'S NOT ON
OUR AGENDA THERE ARE PROPOSALS
FOR A BOND. AND THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE TWO HOUSES RIGHT NOW
VISIT THE SENATE IS INTERESTED
IN INCLUDING HIGHER EDUCATION
BUT THE ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL DOES
NOT. AND I HAPPENED TO SEE
PRIVATE POLLING THAT SHOWS.
THERE'S MORE SUPPORT FOR THE K.
THROUGH TWELVE THEY'RE STILL
SUPPORT FOR HIGHER EDUCATION BUT
WE HAVE TO NAVIGATE THAT BUT IT
IT. IT JUST IT IS A BONE OF
CONTENTION AND SO- I THINK THOSE
LONG RANGE PLANS ONLY GO SO FAR
RIGHT NOW IT'S WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN BUT THERE'S NO COMMITMENT
TO MAKE IT HAPPEN AND- AND TO
CONNECT THE ENROLLMENT WITH THE
ACADEMIC OR PHYSICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN INCREMENTS.
BUT THAT THAT LEADS TO THE- THE
OTHER TWO QUESTIONS I HAVE BEEN
MAYBE. MAYBE WE SHOULD TALK
ABOUT ONE OF THEM UNDER HOUSING
BUT BUT- THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AT SANTA CRUZ HAS
SAID IN THEIR LATEST LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT PLAN AND- THEY WILL
NOT. THAT NEW HOUSING WILL COVER
ALL NEW STUDENTS A. AND SORT OF
BUT- I CAN'T TELL IF THERE'S AN
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM SO. SO HOW
DOES THAT WORK. HOW WILL WORK TO
MEET THE TERMS OF THE OUR T. PAY
THAT THE KNOWN ROMAN CROSS WON'T
HAPPEN UNLESS THERE'S HOUSING.
AND THAT'S TO UC. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION SIR I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT OUR
RD PEACE ARE KIND OF GUIDANCE
DOCUMENTS. AND THAT THEY ARE NOT
INTENDED TO- STRICTLY SAY YEAR
TO YEAR HOW GROSS WILL OCCUR. IN
ADDITION- WE GET. OUR
INVOLVEMENT GROSS NUMBERS FROM.
THE LEGISLATURE AND THAT
ENROLLMENT GROWTH CAN OCCUR
WITHIN A SINGLE YEAR. BUT IT
TAKES A THREE YEARS SOMETIMES
LONGER TO BUILD A NEW BUILDING
TO ACCOMMODATE GROWTH SO. THE
ACADEMIC BUILDING SPACE ARE
ADDITIONS AND IN ROMAN GROWS ARE
MOVING ON PARALLEL TRACKS BUT
NOT ALWAYS AND- STEADY
ALIGNMENT- CAPITAL SPACE IS
OFTEN A LAGGING. INDICATOR TO
THE ENROLLMENT GROSS- THE CAMPUS
OF CENTER IF THEY ARE ABLE TO
CONSTRUCT THEIR NEW FACILITIES-
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO ACCOMMODATE
THE ENROLLMENT GROSS THAT THEY
WANT TO TAKE ON THAT CAMPUS- BUT
THAT ABILITY FOR THAT CAMPUS TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THOSE NEW
PROJECTS. IS OF COURSE DEPENDENT
ON A MULTITUDE OF FACTORS. I
AGREE BUT IT IT IS ALWAYS. A
WHAT WAS JUST REFERRED TO AS A
GUIDANCE DOCUMENT IS NOT
ACCEPTED ALL THE TIME BY COURTS
AS BEING A GUIDE GUIDANCE
DOCUMENT- ARE THERE LOOKING FOR
ACTUAL. IMPLEMENTATION AND I
THINK IT'S THE REASON THERE'S-
DIFFICULT RELATIONS WITH OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS IS. IT'S ARE WE
MEAN WHAT WE SAY BUT IT'S JUST A
GUIDANCE DOCUMENT. AND THEREFORE
THINGS WILL HAPPEN THAT AREN'T
REALLY ARE CONSISTENT WITH THE
GUIDANCE DOCUMENT WHICH
ACTUALLY. SICK WHAT COULD COULD
HAVE AN IMPACT ON AND- AND I
WILL SPARE THE COMMITTEE THAT.
THE SECOND DOOR THAT YOU OPENED
IT'S JUST I'M DESPERATELY TRYING
TO HELP THE UNIVERSITY WITH THAT
THREE THOUSAND UNIT PROJECTED.
IT IN SANTA CRUZ BUT DON'T WANT
TO HELP THEMSELVES THEY WANT TO
BUILD A HUNDRED FIFTY UNITS ON A
MEADOW AND IF THEY JUST MOVED A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY. TO WHERE THE
OTHER TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED AND
FIFTY A PARTICULAR LAWSUIT WOULD
GO AWAY THEY COULD MOVE ON AND
WE WOULD BRING ALL THESE PEOPLE
IN SUPPORT BUT IT. CAN'T SOMEHOW
IT CAN'T EVER BE FIGURED. OUT IT
KEEPS THE CONFLICT GO.
INDIFFERENT ARE WHICH WHICH TO
LAST. HOME AND THAT IS IT'S THE
RELATED QUESTION OF. THERE IS
ALL THE TALK OF ENROLLMENT
GROWTH BUT WATER THE PAY AND I
KNOW YOU JUST SAID THAT ARE ALL
THE SELLER DP'S. BUT HOW WAS UC
PLANNING FOR THE PHYSICAL
LOCATION OF THE GROWTH THAT IS
PLANNED IN THE CELLAR DP'S I
MEAN WHERE'S IT GOING AND HOW
ARE YOU GOING TO DEAL WITH THE
FACT THAT MAYBE NOT ALL OF IT
CAN BE ACCOMMODATED ON THE
EXISTING CAMPUSES WATER YOUR
LONG RANGE PLANS TO DEAL WITH.
WITH PHYSICAL PLANT TO
ACCOMMODATE GROWTH. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTIONS. BUT IN THE
LONG RUN WE INTEND TO UTILIZE
MANY METHODS TO ACCUMULATE- TOOK
ON THE DATE OUR NEW ENROLLMENT
GROWTH. WE ARE GOING TO BE
INCREASING ONLINE COURSES- THE
GOVERNOR'S POLICY GOAL SET THE
GOAL OF DOUBLING OUR ONLINE
COURSES OR ONLINE UNITS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY. WE'RE GOING TO
INCREASE OUR SUMMER SESSIONS
OFFERINGS TO TRY TO GET STUDENTS
TO MOVE THROUGH THE UNIVERSITY
FASTER IF THEY TAKE SUMMER
SESSION COURSES WE CAN GET THEM
TO GRADUATE FASTER. AND THEY
WILL OPEN UP NEW SPACES ARE
THERE SPACES WILL OPEN UP FOR
NEW STUDENTS. WERE ALSO GOING TO
LOOK AT FUNDING MECHANISMS FOR
NEW FACILITIES- ON OUR CAMPUSES
I KNOW THE LEGISLATURE HAS THE-
HIGHER EDUCATION AFFORDABLE
STUDENT HOUSING GRANT PROGRAM-
AND YOU'RE LOOKING AT OTHER
POSSIBLE STUDENT HOUSING FUNDING
MECHANISMS. THAT WOULD ALLOW TO
UNIVERSITY TO ACCESS THE
FINANCING NECESSARY TO CONSTRUCT
ADDITIONAL- HOUSING FOR STUDENTS. IT'S JUST A COMMENT WHICH IS
AWESOME ON THE CSU SIDE ARE WE
DEALT WITH THE FACT THAT WE
STANISLAUS STATE THEY'RE GOING
TO DO A CENTERED STOCKTON THAT
WAS FUNDED BY THE LEGISLATURE
LAST YEAR THAT WHILE COMMITTED
ADDITIONAL GROWTH THAT MIGHT NOT
A FIT ON THE CAMPUS. AND OUR WAS
ALWAYS A PROPONENT OF THE MILLS
COLLEGE ACQUISITION WHICH SEEMS
LIKE IT MIGHT HAVE PROBLEMS
THESE DAYS BUT IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT THERE ARE ALSO
OPPORTUNITIES TO HAVE
INDEPENDENT SITES AFFILIATED
WITH CAMPUSES TO GET TO THE
GROWTH ISSUES AND THAT'S JUST
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD TRY TO
HELP YOU WITH. I'M THAT
COMPLETES MY QUESTIONS AND I
DON'T HAVE ONE I THINK OF FROM
SENATOR MAN SO LET ME ASK CENTER
ROADSHOW BOGUS IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS ON THIS ITEM. THANK
YOU SO MUCH- THE DISCUSSION IS
THE VERY MEANS ENGAGING FOR.
PERMEATE BECAUSE I ACTUALLY HAVE
ABOUT. I'VE ACTUALLY WE THINK
HOW DO I. THERE WERE THE
UNIVERSE TO HAVE A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF GROWTH AND AB AND IT.
BASICALLY PLACE IT ON THE
UNIVERSITIES TO FACILITATE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BOTH WITH HE AT
TEACHER AND THE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND I TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION IS
THINKING ABOUT AND THE REASON I
WAS THINKING ABOUT IT I WAS
THINKING ABOUT THE- THE- MY
GOODNESS I JUST. LOST MY TRAIN
OF THOUGHT THE- THE DEFER THEIR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE COST OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS JUST. IN
MY OPINION JUST GROWING
EXPONENTIALLY IN BUT WE'RE
ALLOCATING TOWARDS A DEFERRED
PAYMENT AND I THOUGHT WE'RE NOT
MAINTAINING THE STRUCTURES AND-
FOR THE DAY INTERPRETERS THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE. HOW DO WE EXPECT
THAT THESE STUDENTS TO COME IN
AND ACTUALLY- HAVE BOTH TEACHERS
AND CLASSES COURSES OFFERED IN A
FACILITY TO ATTEND BUT I CAN
UNDERSTAND THE ONLINE ENROLLMENT
PROCESS AND HOW THAT WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL- IN. IN MITIGATING
THE NEW AND ROMAN BUT- I AM
STILL VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE- ASPECT OF
OUR UNIVERSITIES- OUR WHOLE
INFRASTRUCTURE ACTUALLY
THROUGHOUT YOU KNOW OUR OUR
FROM. K. ALL THE WAY TO. OUR OUR
UNIVERSITIES AND THEY THE FOR
PAYMENTS ARE DUE FOR MAINTENANCE
ON THAT ASPECT SO. MY CONCERN
WAS WERE EXPECTING THESE
UNIVERSITIES TO ENROLL AN X.
AMOUNT OF STUDENTS. AND YET
WE'RE NOT OUT ARE WE'RE NOT OUT
OF ALLOTTING. A SPECIFIC AMOUNT
ARE ENOUGH IN MY OPINION- TO THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE RICHEST
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT THEN AGAIN. I
TOOK NOTE IN HERE THAT- THE NEAR
ROMAN FUNDING WOULD GO TOWARDS
NEW HIRING WHICH WOULD BE
HELPFUL IN COURSE- AVAILABILITY
BECAUSE THAT IS ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT I OFTEN ALSO HERE
IS THAT OUR STUDENTS DON'T HAVE
COURSE. AT COURSES THAT THEY
HAVE ACCESS TO IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO GRADUATE SO. IN THE BACK
OF A MIND THING HOW DO WE
MITIGATE THAT HOW DO WE EXPECT
YOU TO GROW. BUT YET. THERE
ISN'T THERE DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
CURRENTLY ENOUGH CLASSES OUR
COURSES- FOR STUDENTS TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO GRADUATE
SO. THERE WAS A DISPARITY
THURMOND WAS TRYING SO THANK YOU
I ACTUALLY APPRECIATE- YOUR LINE
OF QUESTIONING NURSING. CENTER
LARRY- AS FAR AS THE QUESTION-
C. SO I HAVE ONE FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND IT'S-
WHAT IS THE REASON FOR FUNDING
AND ROAMING GROWTH GIVEN THE
DISPARITY BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSED GROWTH AND THE
UC'S EXPECTED GROWTH. THANKS FOR
THE QUESTION SENATOR. SOLDIERS
SAY THAT BASED ON WHAT WE HEARD
WITH ALL THE PRESENTATIONS AND-
THE EARLIER QUESTIONS- IT YOU
KNOW IT HAD ALL REPEAT THAT THIS
IS A COMPLEX ISSUE- UC'S ROLE
MEANT LEVEL FOR. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION IS. ARE OUR
CURRENT PROPOSAL IS USING THE
BASELINE OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AT TWO. TO FUND- SIXTY TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX NEW
UNDERGRADUATES IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. FOR THAT WOULD BE
SIXTY SEVEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
ONGOING GENERAL FUND THAT WOULD
SUPPORT THAT. HOWEVER WE'RE
WE'RE OPEN DUE TO THE COMPLEXITY
TO CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND WITH
YOU SEE TO MAKE SURE WE GET A
REST. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH I THINK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THANK YOU TO THE MEMBERS OF
THIS PANEL. THANKS FOR INDULGING
ME ASKING AN ENROLLMENT QUESTION
UNDER ISSUE ONE. HUNDRED WEEKS
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IT WHETHER IT
WAS AT THE RIGHT TIME. WE'RE
GONNA MOVED ISSUE THREE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY. AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SAME PANELISTS LET'S
BEGIN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES A HUNDRED MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND. FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY. ALL AND THAT BILL
LAST YEAR THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT INCLUDED THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THE SAME
PURPOSE SO WE'RE TRYING TO BUILD
ON THE PREVIOUS- INVESTMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. YOUR
ASSESSMENT OF THIS PROPOSAL IS A
MESSAGE THAT YOU'LL HEAR US
REPEAT THROUGHOUT THE YEAR WHICH
IS WE THINK THAT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE IS A REASONABLE USE
OF ONE TIME FINDING. A DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS IF THEY
AREN'TADDRESSED- IN THE BUDGET
YEAR THEY WILL HAVE TO BE
ADDRESSED IN THE FUTURE YOU'RE
AT A HIGHER COST CHAU DRESSING
THEM NOW. HELPS IMPROVE THE
UNIVERSITY IN THE STATE'S BUDGET
RESILIENCY. THE PROPOSAL ALSO
SUPPORTED ENERGY EFFICIENCY
PROJECTS AND THOSE ARE
REASONABLE TOO TO THE EXTENT
THAT THEY RESULT IN- ONGOING-
UTILITY SAVINGS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY. NOW THAT SAID AS
SOME OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
NOTED IN THE PREVIOUS ISSUE-
THERE IS A BIGGER ISSUE AT HAND
WE WOULD DIRECT YOUR ATTENTION
TO THE THIRD BACKGROUND
PARAGRAPH ON PAGE FIFTEEN. AND
IN THAT PARAGRAPH YOU'LL SEE
THAT YOU SEE ESTIMATES ITS
EXISTING MAINTENANCE BACKLOG TO
BE SEVEN POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS. AND ON TOP OF THAT YOU
SEE ESTIMATES IT HAS A TEN YEAR
CAPITAL RENEWAL NEED OF TWELVE
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS.
THAT MEANS THAT THE UNIVERSITY
ESTIMATES IT WOULD HAVE TO SPEND
AROUND ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS EACH YEAR TO KEEP THAT
SEVEN POINT THREE BILLION DOLLAR
BACKLOG FROM GROWING FURTHER.
FOR COMPARISON YOU SEE CURRENTLY
SPEND JUST UNDER THREE HUNDRED
MILLION ANNUALLY ON MAINTENANCE.
SO THAT'S A DIFFERENCE
APPROACHING A BILLION DOLLARS IN
TERMS OF FUNDING. THE GIVEN THE
HIGH BACKLOG WE RECOMMEND THAT
THELEGISLATURE TREAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED- FUNDING
LEVEL FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
AS A STARTING POINT. POTENTIALLY
PROVIDING A MORE FUNDS FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IF THEY
BECOME AVAILABLE MAY REVISION OR
EVEN FUNDS FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE OF THE OTHER STATE
AGENCIES TO THE EXTENT THE
LEGISLATURE- HAS CONCERNS THAT
WITH DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND
OTHER AGENCIES. TO SERVE A
LONGER TERM STRATEGY TO ADDRESS
UC'S MAINTENANCE NEEDS. GIVEN
SORT OF THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
ISSUE IT'S UNLIKELY THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD BE ABLE TO
COME UP WITH A LONG TERM
STRATEGY BY THE END OF THIS
BUDGET CYCLE BUT IT'S SOMETHING
THE LEGISLATURE COULD START
CONSIDERING. TERMS OF HOW MUCH
FUNDING TO PROVIDE OVER WHAT
PERIOD OF TIME. ALL THE ROLE OF
THE LEGISLATURE VERSUS THE
UNIVERSITY IN ADDRESSING THESE
ISSUES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR FOR
PAST SUPPORT FOR THE
UNIVERSITIES DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE EFFORTS THE
APPROPRIATIONS RECEIVED IN PRIOR
YEARS INCLUDING THE FUNDING FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE ASSESSMENTS HAVE
HELPED TO RESOLVE EMERGENCY
SYSTEM FAILURES AND HAVE A LOT
OF THE CAMPUS AGAIN A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THEIR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE NEEDS. FOR TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONE TIME INVESTMENTS TO
ADDRESS UC'S CRITICAL DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS CAMPUSES
WILL UTILIZE THESE FUNDS TO
RENEW BUILDING SYSTEMS ENSURE
LIFE SAFETY STANDARDS AND
IMPROVE ENERGY EFFICIENCY IN
CAMPUS BUILDINGS I REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS PROPOSED
INVESTMENT. THE UNIVERSITY
OCCUPIES APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED
AND FORTY SIX MILLION GROSS
SQUARE FEET OF SPACE OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS CAMPUS IS ENGAGED
IN AN EXTENSIVE PROCESS TO
EVALUATE THE COST OF CAPITAL
OUTLAY RENEWAL NEEDS AND
DETERMINES THAT SYSTEM WIDE.
CAMPUSES HAVE TWELVE POINT THREE
BILLION AND NEED THIS AMOUNT
INCLUDES A SIZABLE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG AND SEISMIC
RENOVATIONS FAR AGING BUILDINGS.
THE UNIVERSITY USES TO
INTEGRATED CAPITAL ASSET
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM OR I CAN'T
DETRACT DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
NEEDS THE MOST CRITICAL PROJECTS
IN THE LIST ARE BRED IN THE I
CAN'T SYSTEM AND THE UNIVERSITY
CURRENTLY HAS ABOUT SEVEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION AND
READ CATEGORY DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS. THE
FUNDING PROVIDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE LAST BUDGET
I'M PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR FOR
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE WILL HELP
THE UNIVERSITY MAKES SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS ON ADDRESSING THESE
CRITICAL PROJECTS. STILL THE
UNIVERSITY'S CAPITAL NEEDS ARE
GREAT AND WE ARE REQUESTING THE
LEGISLATURE FOR ONE POINT SIX
BILLION TO ADDRESS A COMBINATION
OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE SEISMIC
PROJECTS A NEW ACADEMIC
FACILITIES. THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS IN REDUCING OUR
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS OUR
CAMPUSES RECEIVE A THIRD. OF
THEIR ENERGY FROM RENEWABLE-
HOWEVER SIX OF OUR CAMPUS HAVE
THEIR OWN NOT GAS HEATING PLANTS
BECAUSE- AND THEN I. NINETIES
DECOMMISSIONING THOSE FACILITIES
WILL TAKE TIME AND WILL BE
EXPENSIVE BUT IS NECESSARY FOR
THE UNIVERSITY TO ACHIEVE
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN CARBON
EMISSIONS. BECAUSE OF THIS OUR
REQUEST INCLUDES CAMPUS
DECARBONISATION STUDIES. IN
TERMS OF THE COMMITTEE'S
QUESTION ON HOW THESE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS CAN BE
ADDRESSED. WE YOU HAVE VARIOUS
FUNDING INSTRUMENTS THAT YOU CAN
AUTHORIZE DIRECT APPROPRIATIONS
ARE PREFERABLE FOR SMALLER
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
THAT KEEP COMING UP AS
INFRASTRUCTURE AGES. FOR SEISMIC
RENOVATION IN DIRECT
APPROPRIATIONS OR GRANTS ARE NOT
AVAILABLE WE WOULD FAVOR AND NO
INTEREST REVOLVING LOAN FUND
DEDICATED FOR THAT PURPOSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ARM I HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS FROM SENATOR
MAN BUT LET ME JUST ASK A GLOBAL
ONE FIRS AND I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S- WHO WHO COULD ANSWER IT
BUT IT WAS JUST SAID THAT ONE
POINT SIX BILLION IS THE BACKLOG
A HUNDRED MILLION THIS. IS IN
THE BUDGET- FOR UC. IT IS IN
YOUR BACK OR GREATER THAN ONE
POINT SIX BILLION OR SET YOUR
TOTAL BACKLOG- NO I REQUEST IS
ONE POINT SIX BILLION FOR THE-
FOUR. TWENTY THREE- LET'S JUST
BE LINEAR YOUR TOTAL AMOUNT OF
BACKLOG. YOUR REQUEST AND WHAT'S
RECOMMENDED SO IF ONE POINT SIX
BILLION IS WHAT YOU'RE
REQUESTING HUNDRED MILLION IS
WHAT'S RECOMMENDED WHAT YOUR
TOTAL AMOUNT OF. THE TOTAL
AMOUNT OF NEED IS ABOUT TWELVE
POINT THREE BILLION OKAY THANK
YOU. AND THEN US SENATOR MAN
WANTED TO ASK THE QUESTION OF
FOR UC'S BACKLOG AMOUNT HOW MUCH
WOULD BE CONSIDERED SHOVEL READY
OR COULD BE STARTED IN THE NEXT
YEAR IF IT WERE FUNDED. THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION SIR
BECAUSE OF OUR ID CAMPS SYSTEM
WE HAVE ARE PROJECTS WELL
DEFINED- WE COULD GET GOING VERY
QUICKLY ON THESE CRITICAL
PROJECTS THAT ARE. ALREADY ALL
LOGGED IN OUR SYSTEM THAT'S
SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT
MILLION IN PROJECTS THAT I
DISCUSSED. SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WILL SLOW DOWN HOW QUICKLY
CAMPUSES CAN GET STARTED. IS
THAT WE DO NEED TO HAVE
CONTRACTS FOR- PROJECTS WITH
THE- WITH THE CONSTRUCTION FIRM
THAT COMES IN TO TAKE CARE OF
STOP WORK OR OR TO TRADES-
INDIVIDUALS OF WE HIRE. SO BUT
BASICALLY SEVEN HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS OF
PROJECTS ARE SHOVEL READY
PENDING THE ABILITY TO GET
CONTRACTORS AND WORKERS SECONDS
CORRECT OKAY THANK YOU AND THEN.
A SENATOR MEN'S OTHER QUESTION-
WAS. I THINK IT'S OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. ARM R. Y.
IF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROJECTS
DON'T COUNT TOWARD AGAIN LIMIT
IS THE ADMINISTRATION ONLY
PUTTING FORTH A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WHEN A MUCH LARGER
INVESTMENT COULD REDUCE THE
TOTAL BACKLOG. AND COUNT AGAINST
AGAIN LIMIT. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- CENTER LAYERED- MEN BE
A LAYER- SO WE'RE- OUR OUR
PROPOSAL IS FOR A HUNDRED
MILLION DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
THAT'S THAT'S HOW WE LANDED IN
STRUCTURING THE OVERALL BUDGET-
AND THINKING ABOUT THAT CAN
LIMIT. AND I ALL KNOW THAT THAT
YOU KNOW THE- SEVERAL VOICES
HAVE HAVE I HAVE EMPHASIZED THAT
THIS IS A BIG ISSUE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS SHOWN THAT IT
IS- DEDICATED TO THINKING ABOUT
THIS AND DOING SOMETHING ON IT
ALL ALL AGAIN SAY THAT THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
INCLUDED THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE MILLION- THAT WAS SOMETHING
WE WERE IN FAVOR OF- THIS
HUNDRED MILLION. IS IT IS WHERE
WE LANDED FOR THIS PROPOSAL BUT
MAY REVISE- IS ALWAYS ANOTHER
MOMENT IN TIME. THANK YOU FOR OF
FOR. THAT IS SEMI CRYPTIC
COMMENTED ACTUALLY CONVEYED A
LOT OF MEANING SO- APPRECIATE
THAT AND AS I SAID IN ONE OF THE
PREVIOUS HEARING STUFF THE JAN
TEN BUDGET ARE USUALLY BEARS NO
RESEMBLANCE TO THE BUDGET
ADOPTED IN JUNE AND A LOT OF
TIMES IT'S THE ONE TIME THINGS
WHETHER IT'S A PERSON STIRS BY
DOWN OR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
THAT ACCOUNT FOR SOME OF THE
DIFFERENCES REPORT NUMBERS. AT
THE END I DID THAT COMPLETE YOUR
QUESTIONS ARE CENTER JOB OKAY
THAT COMPLETES OUR QUESTIONS WE
THANK YOU AND WE KNOW THAT'S A
MOVING TARGET OF WILL MOVE TO
ISSUE NMBER FOR VARIOUS
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS AND WE HAVE
THE SAME PANELISTS WILL GO IN
THE SAME ORDER WILL START WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SOME
COVERING IN THIS ITEM- THREE
PROPOSALS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THE FIRST IS TEN MILLION
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND. LEVY FOR
RESEARCH ON DYSLEXIA AT THE- UC
SAN FRANCISCO DYSLEXIA CENTER
ALL NOTED THAT BUILDS ON
PREVIOUS INVESTMENTS AT THE SAME
CENTER. AND THE OTHER IS EIGHTY
TWO MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND
INVESTMENT AT THE UNIVERSITY. OF
CALIFORNIA FIREARM VIOLENCE
RESEARCH CENTER THAT'S LOCATED
AT DAVIS. AND THE THIRD IS. A
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT- THIS IS A
BIT WONKY BUT WE'RE WE'RE
PROPOSING TO DECREASE THE
GENERAL FUND BACK FILL FOR YOU
SEE. THIS RELATED TO PROPERTY
SIX REVENUES. ESSENTIALLY UC.
NEEDS A FORTY MILLION DOLLAR
TOTAL TO STAY WHERE THEY'VE BEEN
I WITH THAT PROGRAM AND THIS
TECHNICAL JUSTIN WOULD KEEP THEM
THERE. DID YOU KNOW IT'S REALLY
ROCKY OF FINANCE TEST TO
IDENTIFY THIS WONKY. BECAUSE
USUALLY THAT'S WHERE YOU GO SO
LET'S GO TO THE L. A. HOW THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS. SOME OF
THE THREE PROPOSALS AND THIS
ISSUE- WE RAISE CONCERNS WITH
JUST ONE PROPOSAL AND THAT IS
THE- PROPOSAL AROUND DYSLEXIA
RESEARCH- FOR MORE BACKGROUND-
PAGE TWENTY OF YOUR AGENDA-
PROVIDES MORE INFORMATION ON THE
UC SAN FRANCISCO DYSLEXIA
CENTER. AND IS THE MINISTRATION
NOTED OF THE STATE HAS PROVIDED
ONE TIME FUNDING IN PREVIOUS
YEARS FOR THE CENTER ARE
PRIMARILY AROUND A DEVELOPING
NEW SCREENING TOOLS THAT- OFF A
FLAG REALLY INDICATIONS OF
LEARNING CHALLENGES AMONG
KINDERGARTEN AND FIRST GRADE
STUDENTS- THE IDEA HERE IS THAT
THE SCREENING TOOLS WILL ALLOW
FOR EARLY INTERVENTIONS. ARE
POTENTIALLY IMPROVING-
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES FOR
STUDENTS IN THE LONG RUN AND
EVEN POTENTIALLY PREVENTING SOME
STUDENTS FROM HAVING TO BE
REFERRED FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION.
THIS OVERALL OBJECTIVE- SEEMS
REASONABLE TO US- BUT WE'RE
CONCERNED WITH SOME OF THE
SPECIFIC ELEMENTS OF THE
PROPOSAL. FRANKLY WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT THE I TO DATE THE
LEGISLATURE REALLY HASN'T SET
STATUTORY- GUIDELINES ARE
FRAMEWORK AROUND THE INITIATIVE
IT'S REALLY BEEN DRIVEN BY THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
UNIVERSITY. AND WE'RE CONCERNED
THAT WITHOUT SOME GUIDELINES THE
LEGISLATURE COULD RUN THE RISK
OF FACING UP UNLESS YOU LIVE
WITH. A GROWING SCOPE AND
GROWING COSTS THAT IT DIDN'T
NECESSARILY INTEND TO COMMIT TO
- OF FOR THE PROPOSED- FUNDING
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET- YOU CAN
TURN TO PAGE TWENTY ONE THE
FIGURE ON THAT. IT SHOWS HOW THE
CENTER WOULD BE- SPEND THE FUNDS
AND EVEN SUSPENDED YOUR PLAN-
YOU KNOW THERE DOES SEEM TO BE A
BIT OF A BROAD IN SCOPE- THE-
PLAN IS TO ADD MORE
FUNCTIONALITY TO THE- ABSURD
EXISTING TOOLS IN PLACE. AND
THEN ALSO TO. FUND OTHER
ACTIVITIES LIKE BASIC RESEARCH.
OUR SECOND CONCERN IS THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DATE HASN'T
PROVIDED THE LEGISLATURE A LONG
TERM PLAN TO SCALE- THE- POLLS.
THE LEGISLATURE REALLY DOESN'T
HAVE A GOOD SENSE OF WHAT THE
LONG TERM PLAN IS TO. IMPLEMENT
THE CENTERS SCHOOLS STATEWIDE-
AND ALSO DISCUSS UNIT COSTS WITH
FURTHER DEVELOPMENT WITH
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
TEACHERS. FOR EXAMPLE. SO WE
RECOMMEND OF THE LEGISLATURE IS
INTERESTED IN CONTINUING TO
SUPPORT THIS INITIATIVE TO
PROVIDE SOME STATUTORY GUIDANCE
AND ALSO ADOPTS- REPORTING. ON
TO GET SOME OF THIS ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION SO I CAN MAKE. MORE
INFORMED DECISIONS MOVING
FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF THEN WILL GO TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU. I WILL REVIEW THE PROPOSALS
AND THE ORDER THAT THEY APPEAR
IN YOUR AGENDA. STARTING WITH
FIREARMS RESEARCH. FIREARMS ARE
HEALTH CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA
BETWEEN NINETEEN NINETY NINE AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN ONE CALIFORNIA
AND DIED EVERY THREE HOURS FROM
GUN VIOLENCE. IN TWENTY NINETEEN
ACCORDING TO THE CENTER FOR
DISEASE CONTROL 200-090-0405
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA DIED FROM
GUNSHOT WOUNDS. WERE AFRICAN
AMERICAN MEN BETWEEN THE AGES OF
FIFTEEN AND TWENTY FIVE GUNSHOT
WOUNDS ARE LEAST LEADING CAUSE
OF DEATH. TO ADDRESS THIS PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS THE LEGISLATURE
CODIFIED THE MISSION OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA FIREARM
VIOLENCE RESEARCH CENTER AT UC
DAVIS AS AN ACADEMIC AND POLICY
RESEARCH CENTER. THE CENTERS
AREAS OF ACTIVITY INCLUDE
RESEARCH ASSISTANTS THE POLICY
MAKERS TRAINING AND EDUCATION
FOR RESEARCHERS PRACTITIONERS
AND THE PUBLIC. A MEDICAL AND
HEALTH PROVIDER EDUCATION
TRAINING PROGRAM AND AN OPTIONAL
GRANT PROGRAMS TO FACILITATE
RESEARCH BY OTHERS. THE CENTERS
BALLPOINT PROJECT HAS DEVELOPED
A CURRICULUM TO TEACH MEDICAL
AND MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
ABOUT FIREARM INJURY PREVENTION
THE CENTER IS NOW DISSEMINATING
THIS CURRICULUM AND EVALUATING
ITS EFFECTIVENESS. FIRST OF
CALIFORNIA REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE TWO MILLION PROPOSED TO
CONTINUE THIS CRITICAL WORK. NOW
MOVING ON TO THE DYSLEXIA CENTER
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES TEN
MILLION FOR TO UCSF DYSLEXIA
CENTER TO CONDUCT TRANSLATIONAL
RESEARCH AND BUILD ON THE
CAPACITY OF SCIENCE TO DEVELOP
ASSESSMENT AND INTERVENTION
PRACTICES FOR CHILDREN WITH
DYSLEXIA. THE CENTER IS
DEVELOPING A TOOL CALLED
MULTITUDES THAT WILL PROVIDE
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
INCLUSIVE SCIENCE BASED
ASSESSMENT OF YOUNG CHILDREN FOR
DYSLEXIA. BEST PRACTICES HAVE
TESTED CHILDREN SORRY FAST
PRACTICES I'VE TESTED CHILDREN
IN THIRD GRADE OR LATER ONLY
AFTER IT THEY DEVELOP NOTICEABLE
LEARNING DIFFICULTIES AND THEN
ONLY IN ENGLISH. AT THIS POINT
MANY CHILDREN WITH DYSLEXIA HAVE
ALREADY FALLEN BEHIND IN
LEARNING UNLESS AND HER SPECIAL
INSTRUCTION CLASSROOM MULTITUDES
PROJECT WILL PROVIDE A DIGITAL
PLATFORM TOOL THAT TEACHERS CAN
OPERATE WITH OUR SPECIALIST
PRESENT THE SCREENING WILL TAKE
TWENTY MINUTES WITH A SECOND
TWENTY MINUTES SCREENING FOR
CHILDREN WHO STRUGGLE WITH THE
FIRST STEP. THE SYSTEM SCREENS
KINDERGARTEN AND FIRST GRADE
STUDENTS TO IDENTIFY DIFFERENT
ASPECTS OF RISK FOR LEARNING
CHALLENGES BEFORE STUDENTS
EXPERIENCE FAILURE SCHOOLS CAN
BEGIN EARLY INTERVENTION BEFORE
THE CHILD FALLS BEHIND OR HAS TO
BE. PLACED IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
. OR SO CALLED WERE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
FUNDING. OUR TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE GRADUATE
MEDICAL EDUCATION IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA VOTERS PASSED
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE RESEARCH
AND PREVENTION TOBACCO ACT. PROP
FIFTY SIX ALLOCATES FORTY
MILLION ANNUALLY TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA FOR
STATE WIDE MEDICAL RESIDENCY
GRANT PROGRAM. PROP FIFTY SIX
REVENUES HAVE FALLEN SHORT OF
THE FORTY MILLION GOAL AND THE
STATE HAS STEPPED IN THE FUNDING
GAP WITH STATE GENERAL FUND AND
ENSURE THAT THE ANNUAL PROGRAM
BUDGET REMAINS FORTY MILLION. IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE PROP FIFTY
SIX GME FUNDING PROVIDED TWO
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN MEDICAL
RESIDENCY SLOTS STATEWIDE.
BECAUSE DOCTORS TEND TO TAKE
TEND TO STAY PRACTICING MEDICINE
IN THE AREA WHERE THEY COMPLETED
THEIR RESIDENCY IT IS IN THE
INTEREST OF THE STATE TO
CONTINUE TO OFFER TO USE MEDICAL
RESIDENCY POSITIONS TO ADDRESS
DOCTOR SHORTAGES. UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA REQUEST THAT THE
LEGISLATUR CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
THE STATE GENERAL FUND TOP OFF
FOR THE PROP FIFTY SIX GME
FUNDING. TO FORTY MILLION. AND
VERY QUICKLY I WOULD LIKE TO
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR UC
REGENTS BUDGET REQUEST NOT
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. FIRST THE STUDENT
ACADEMIC PREPARATION AN
EDUCATIONAL PARTNERSHIPS OR
STATE PROGRAM PROVIDES A THROUGH
G. COURSES THE STUDENTS WHOSE
HIGH SCHOOLS DO NOT OFFER A
SUFFICIENT NUMBER OF THOSE
COURSES. IN ADDITION AP COURSES
SUMMER ACADEMIC PREPARATION AND
MENTORING ARE OFFERED TO
ENCOURAGE HIGH SCHOOL AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS TO
ATTEND A FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITY.
WE ARE REQUESTING AN ADDITIONAL
TWENTY TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
FOR THESE PROGRAMS AT A TIME OF
SIGNIFICANT LEARNING IMPACTS AND
LOW INCOME DISTRICT. THESE FUNDS
ARE NEEDED TO ENSURE THE
PANDEMIC GENERATION DOES NOT
LOSE OUT ON HIGHER EDUCATION.
SECOND WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED SIX MILLION
FOR FORMER FOSTER YOUTH SERVICES
AND REQUEST YOUR ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT OR SOME OTHER VULNERABLE
STUDENTS. FIVE MILLION FOUR ARE
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS AND FOUR
MILLION FOR CARCERAL SYSTEM
IMPACTED STUDENTS. THIS FUNDING
WOULD ALLOW CAMPUSES TO
ESTABLISH DEDICATED PROGRAMS FOR
ADVISING AND STUDENT SUPPORT FOR
THE STUDENTS. AND LAST BUT NOT
LEAST FOUR MILLION ONGOING FOR
TWO UC CANCER CONSORTIUM FOR
UNIFIED STRATEGY TO LEVERAGE THE
EXPERTISE STRENGTH AND SCALE OF
THE UC SYSTEM. TO IMPROVE CANCER
CARE AND PATIENT ACCESS AND
BETTER SERVE THE DIVERSE
POPULATION OF CALIFORNIA. THE
CANCER CENTER WOULD PROVIDE
CANCER DATABASE FOR PRECISION
ONCOLOGY ESTABLISHED CLINICAL
TRIALS CREATE TEAMS FOR DISEASE
SPECIFIC CHALLENGES AND OFFER
SECOND OPINIONS TO PATIENTS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU- LET ME JUST SAY TWO THINGS
THE ONE QUESTION I WAS GOING TO
ASK WAS ANSWERED IN THE UC
PROPOSAL ABOUT WHAT ITEMS WERE
NOT. ARE INDEED JANUARY TENTH
BUDGET THAT WERE PRIORITIES OF
THE UNIVERSITY. AND ONE OF THE
REASONS WE HAVE A HARD STOP AT
NOON TODAY'S I'M MEETING WITH
THE CHAIR OF THE BOARD OF
REGENTS AT TWELVE FIFTEEN AND SO
I EXPECT TO HEAR. ABOUT THOSE
WHEN THAT HAPPENS AND SECOND LET
ME JUST NOTE THAT OUR KNOWLEDGE
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE DYSLEXIA
RESEARCH PROPOSAL TO THE
GOVERNOR SO ARE WE ARE WHERE
FACTORED WE WILL LOOK AT THESE
PROPOSAL SETTING FORWARD LET ME
ASK YOU FOR A- IF SENATOR CHOI
BOGUE HAS ANY QUESTIONS ON THIS
ON. SHE HAS NONE THE SENATOR MEN
LEFT NONE FOR ME SO GOING TO
THANK BUT LET ME THANK THE PANEL
OF THE- YOU'RE NOT GOING AWAY.
A. N. AND WE HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
PANELISTS FOR THE NEXT ONE WE
ARE MOVING TO THE- UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE AND
NATURAL RESOURCES ITEM IT IS
OVERSIGHT. THE FIRST BOSS
SPEAKER WILL BE THE L. A. O. THE
SECOND WILL BE- OF CITY OF FROM.
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
THE THIRD WILL BE GLENN GLENDA
HERMISTON WHO'S THE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR AGRICULTURE
NATURAL RESOURCES AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. AND
THEN BRIAN RUTLEDGE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND LET
ME JUST SAY TWO THINGS BEFORE WE
GO TO THE PANELISTS IN THAT
ORDER. ONE IS THAT WE DID A
MAJOR AUGMENTATION LAST YEAR. IN
THE BUDGET TO ATTEMPT TO RESTORE
AND REHABILITATE COOPERATIVE
AGRICULTURAL XTENSION ACROSS
THE STATE. THEN PART OF THE
REASON FOR THIS OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS TO HEAR FOR THE
PROGRESS IN IMPLEMENTING THAT
BUDGET ITEM FROM LAST YEAR. AND
SECONDLY THERE THERE WAS A
REPORT DONE BY THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST ON THIS GENERAL SUBJECT
WHICH I KNOW WILL BE PART OF
THIS SO WE WILL HEAR THAT AS
WELL. SO WE'LL BEGIN WITH THE
REPRESENTATIVE. FROM THE L. A.
L. THIRTY TWO THIRTY- ITEM I
THOUGHT I WOULD. START BY FIRST
PROVIDING SOME BASIC BACKGROUND
ABOUT THE- PROGRAMS IN QUESTION
AND THEN. I MOVED TO THE-
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT. WE
DESCRIBED IN OUR SPECIAL REPORT
THAT THE CHARGES MENTIONED- WE
FEEL. OF KEEPING THIS VERY BRIEF
RECOGNIZING THE LIMITED TIME OF
THE COMMITTEE. JUST TO INTRODUCE
THE PROGRAMS VERY QUICKLY I
USUALLY HAS TWO KEY PROGRAMS
THAT FOCUS ON AGRICULTURAL AND
NATURAL RESOURCE ISSUES THE
FIRST IS CALLED THE AGRICULTURAL
EXPERIMENT STATIONS THIS
PROVIDES BASIC RESEARCH. ON THAT
THREE UC CAMPUSES ON
AGRICULTURAL AND NATURAL
RESOURCE ISSUES. AND THE SECOND
PROGRAM IS CALLED COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION THIS IS MORE ENGAGED
IN TRANSLATIONAL APPLIED
RESEARCH AND ALSO DIRECT
OUTREACH- AND- CONDUCT THESE
ACTIVITIES ACROSS MANY COMMUNITY
BASED SITES AND ON UC CAMPUSES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. BUT YOU
CAN IMAGINE THE TWO PROGRAMS ARE
INTENDED TO WORK TOGETHER WITH
THE AGRICULTURE EXPERIMENT
STATION IS REALLY FOCUSED ON
DOING THAT FOUNDATIONAL RESEARCH
DISCOVERY AND THE COOPERATIVE
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION TURN
TRANSLATING THAT INTO SEVENTEEN
DISSEMINATING THAT INFORMATION
INTO THEIR BROADER COMMUNITY
ACROSS THE STATE. I'M I'M JUST
ANOTHER ASPECT ABOUT THESE
PROGRAMS TO KEEP IN MIND OF
THEIR FOCUS BROADLY ON
AGRICULTURAL NATURAL RESOURCES
BUT ENGAGE IN MANY DIFFERENT
ACTIVITIES RANGING FROM BASIC
RESEARCH TO. RE DEVELOPING NEW
INVENTIONS TO PROVIDING
WORKSHOPS TO FARMERS TO
PROVIDING NUTRITION EDUCATION TO
CALIFORNIA AND ADULTS AND
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE. I'M
SO THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE ENCOMPASSED
IN THESE PROGRAMS. THE PROGRAMS
OVERSEEN BY THE U. C. DIVISION
OF AGRICULTURAL NATURAL
RESOURCES YOU'LL HEAR US REFER
TO IT THROUGHOUT THE ITEM AS YOU
SEE A IN OUR- IN PRACTICE YOU
SEE IN OUR PHONE WAS YOU WERE
OBVIOUSLY LISTENING TO OUR
HEARING YESTERDAY WHERE WE WON'T
WAR AGAINST ACRONYMS NOT BEING
DEFINED BEFORE THEY WERE USED.
SO LET ME CONGRATULATE YOU FOR
DOING THAT WITHOUT HAVING TO BE
PROMPTED BECAUSE YOU CLEARLY
DON'T WORK FOR THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. R. I'M
AFRAID THAT JUST FROZE HIM WITH
CFO HE HE ON FREEZES HERE. I
THINK THE MERE MENTION OF AN
ACRONYM BOB HAS FROZEN THE
SYSTEM. WELL LET'S DO THIS-
LET'S LET HIM SEE IF HE CAN
REJOIN US ON FROZEN AND MOVE TO
A TO SAY HOWEVER THÀNH AND FROM
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
OUR SECOND SPEAKER WILL GIVE HIM
A CHANCE TO CLOSE IF HE REJOINS
. THANK YOU CHIRLA OR- I WOULD
LIKE TO TURN DISCUSSION OF THIS
ITEM OVER TO VICE PRESIDENT PLAN
TO HUMISTON. I THANK YOU SAY HOT
MAN THANK YOU CHAIR LETTER TO
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
THANKS FOR INVITING ME TO SPEAK
BEFORE YOU TODAY AND FOR THE
CONTINUED SUPPORT YOU HAVE SHOWN
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. WE
ARE EXTREMELY GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
INVESTMENT IN UC ANR AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
UPDATE YOU ON OUR PROGRESS TO
RECRUIT AND HIRE UC COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION SCIENTIST. THE LAST
SEVEN MONTHS HAVE BEEN
REMARKABLY BUSY AS WE WORK
SWIFTLY TO POST AND FILL
POSITIONS THAT WILL ALLOW US TO
ENHANCE OUR REACH AND DELIVER
SCIENCE BASED INFORMATION
CURRICULUM PROGRAMMING AND
SOLUTIONS TO ALL CALIFORNIANS.
AS PART OF THE LAND GRANT
PARTNERSHIP THAT WAS DEVELOPED
BETWEEN THE STATE. AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WITH THE
EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO MOORLACH. UC
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION AND THE
AGRICULTURAL EXPERIMENT STATIONS
HAVE ADVANCED SCIENTIFIC
KNOWLEDGE FOR OVER A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY YEARS. WE CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS CURRENT AND FUTURE NEEDS
OF CALIFORNIANS THROUGH
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS TO CLIMATE
CHANGE WILDFIRE MITIGATION PEST
MANAGEMENT. FOOD SECURITY
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
HEALTHEQUITY AND BUILDING THE
NEXT GENERATION OF LEADERS. IN
ADDITION TO OUR NETWORK OF
RESEARCH AND EXTENSION PROGRAMS
AS WELL AS JUST BEING DESCRIBED
UC ANR ALSO DELIVERS EXPERTISE
THROUGH THIRTEEN DIFFERENT
INSTITUTES AND STATEWIDE
PROGRAMS. ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE
OVER TWENTY THOUSAND VOLUNTEERS
THAT HELP DELIVER PROGRAMS LIKE
FOUR H. YOUTH DEVELOPMENT AND
MASTER GARDENERS. A FEW UNIQUE
EXAMPLES OF IMPACT DELIVERED BY
THE UC ANR RESEARCHERS INCLUDE.
NEW SOFTWARE AND PHONE APPS SUCH
AS CROP MANAGE WHICH HELPS
GROWERS TO SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED
WATER AND NITROGEN FERTILIZER
USED WHILE STILL REMAINING
PRODUCTIVITY. YOU DISSIPATE IN
OUR FOUR H. PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
SHOWN TO BE MORE LIKELY TO
PURSUE CAREERS IN STEM. TWICE AS
LIKELY TO GRADUATE COLLEGE AND
MORE LIKELY TO ENGAGE. IN
COMMUNITY ENRICHMENT PROJECTS.
PROGRAM FINDINGS FROM TWENTY
TWO. INDICATE THAT NUTRITION.
PROTEST REPORTED AN AVERAGE
MONTHLY FOOD COST SAVINGS OF
OVER FIFTY EIGHT DOLLARS WHICH
COLLECTIVELY SAVED LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES OVER ONE AND
A HALF MILLION DOLLARS. TO
ENHANCE PROGRAM DELIVERY WE
CONTINUALLY SEEK TO BETTER
LEVERAGE STATE FUNDING THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE RATIO IS TWO
POINT FOUR DOLLARS GENERATED PER
EACH STATE DOLLAR WE RECEIVE. IN
THE LAST FEW YEARS WE HAVE ADDED
MULTIPLE CO FUNDED POSITIONS AND
EXPANDED PARTNERSHIPS FOR
EXAMPLE BY HIRING ADDITIONAL
CLIMATE SMART EDUCATION
AGRICULTURE EDUCATORS THANK
CREATING THE NEW UC ORGANIC
AGRICULTURE INSTITUTE. THANKS TO
THE ONGOING AUGMENTATION OF THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET FOR
YOU SEE A AND R. WE HAVE ACTED
QUICKLY TO REBUILD THE UC
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION FOOTPRINT.
ALL THE POSITIONS IDENTIFIED IN
THE MARCH TWENTY TWENTY ONE ARE
STILL THE FOCAL POINT OF THE
HIRING PLAN WE ALSO IMPLEMENTED
A SEPARATE PROCESS TO ENSURE
IDENTIFICATION OF THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY ACADEMIC POSITIONS
ACROSS ALL DISCIPLINARY IS FOR
TODAY AND INTO THE FUTURE. THIS
INVOLVED COMMUNICATING WITH
COMMUNITY PARTNERS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO IDENTIFY THE
MOST PRESSING NEEDS AND
PRIORITIZE NEXT ROUND OF FIRING
OF NOTE. THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
WE HAVE OPEN SUBMITTALS FOR
PLACEMENT OF UC COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION SPECIALIST. WHO ALL
TEN CAMPUSES. TODAY ELEVEN
EXTENSION ADVISORS AND SPECIAL
HAVE BEEN A HIGH AND ARE IN FEEL
. WELL THIRTY FIVE MORE ARE
CURRENTLY UNDER RECRUITMENT AND
EXPECTED TO BE HIGHER BEFORE
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY TWO. YOU SEE
A IN OUR WILL BE ANNOUNCING OVER
FORTY ADDITIONAL NEW ADVISOR
POSITIONS UP TO TWENTY
SPECIALIST POSITIONS LATER THIS
SPRING WE'VE EXPANDED RECRUITING
CAPACITY AND ENHANCED HIRING
PRACTICES TO MEET. THE EVOLVING
DEMANDS OF THE JOB MARKET AND
ENSURE SUCCESS. YOU SEE A AND
R'S COMMITTED TO HIRING A
DIVERSE AND INCLUSIVE WORKFORCE
THAT REFLECTS THE TOP TALENT
NECESSARY TO SOLVE SOCIETAL
PROBLEMS. WE WILL PROVIDE THE
COMMITTEE WITH A BUDGET AND
IMPACT REPORT LATER THIS SPRING.
IN CLOSING THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME TO TALK ABOUT UC ANR
BEEN CLOSE TO MY HEART. IN FACT
THREE OF FOUR H. PLAQUE YOU SEE
BEHIND ME WAS A GIFT FROM MY
FATHER AT CHRISTMAS THIS PAST
YEAR. IT WAS ATTACHED TO OUR
HOUSE WHEN I WAS A CHILD AND FOR
H. AND I ATTRIBUTE MY FOR EACH
EXPERIENCE LARGELY TO WHERE I AM
TODAY. I FIRMLY BELIEVE IN THE
MISSION OF COOPERATIVE EXTENSION
AND ITS ABILITY TO FIND
SOLUTIONS TO THE MANY CHALLENGES
FACING CALIFORNIA. AS WE ENHANCE
OUR PROGRAMS AND ENSURE THAT WE
ARE BEST SERVING ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES IT'S AN HONOR TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO LEAVE. UC ANR
I LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR OUR IN A
MOMENT I'M GONNA GO BACK TO MR
CONSTANT TOURISTS- TO SEE IF HE
WANTS TO FINISH HIS COMMENTS BUT
I CAN'T RESIST ANSWER QUESTIONS
NOT WHERE WAS THE- FOR H. PLAQUE
WHERE DID WHERE DID YOU GROW UP
WHERE THAT. PRODUCT FOR MY
FAMILY'S CATTLE RANCH IN
SOUTHWEST COLORADO. WHICH MY
FATHER IS STILL RUNNING. THAT'S
GREAT WELL. SORRY WE DON'T HAVE
MORE TIME I'D ASK LOCK. ABOUT
THE SO. LET'S GO ON TO MY TRUMP
TOURISTS. MY APOLOGIES TO THE
CAN AND APPRECIATION FOR VICE ON
THE STAND FOR MAKING UP WHERE I
. WHERE I DROPPED OUT DON'T
WORRY I. WAS EMCEEING AN EVENT
RECENTLY REMOTE WAY AND IT
DROPPED IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
EVENT SO I TOTALLY APPRECIATE
WHAT WHAT HAPPENED A PLEASE
FINISH YOUR COMMENTS. ARE YOU IT
SOUNDED LIKE- ADVICE PRESIDENT
HOMESTEAD PROVIDED MORE DETAIL
ON THE PROGRAM TOO SO I THINK WE
CAN SKIP RIGHT FOR THE SECOND
TIME RIGHT TO OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS- THANK YOU SEE
OUR SPECIAL REPORT. THE REASON
WHY WE WERE- WE UNDERTOOK IT WAS
ME- WANTED TO SERVE BETTER
ASSESS HOW THE STATE MOVING
FORWARD CO TO DROUGHT- BUDGET
FOR. ARE YOU SEE A IN OUR AND
GIVEN THE FACT THAT IT'S ONLY
RECENTLY STARTED A LINE ITEM
BUDGETING. FOR THE DIVISION. AND
SO WHAT ARE YOU CAN A RIGHT. ON
PAGE FOUR. OF YOUR CHEN. AND I
IT SOUNDS LIKE I THINK I'LL
SPEND THE MOST TIME ON OUR FIRST
RECOMMENDATION GIVEN THAT THE
AGENDA ASKS US TO ELABORATE A
LITTLE MORE ON IT AND THEN ALL
OF. LEAVE THE OTHER TWO
RECOMMENDATIONS JUST AT A HIGH
LEVEL. THE AVAILABLE FOR Q. NA-
EACH STORE FIRST RECOMMENDATION
IS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
INCORPORATE STATE FUNDING FOR
THE AGRICULTURAL EXPERIMENT
STATION PROGRAMMED INTO THE LINE
ITEM. CURRENTLY THE LINE ITEM
PROVIDES FUNDING FOR YOU SEE A
IN OUR WHICH- REALLY ESSENTIAL
EFFECTIVELY PROVIDES FUNDING FOR
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION. YOU SEE
STILL HAS FLEXIBILITY TO
DETERMINE FUNDING FOR THE
EXPERIMENT STATION PROGRAM. OUR
REASONING WE HAVE TWO REASONS
WHY WE THINK THIS APPROACH WOULD
MAKE SENSE LOOKING FORWARD. THE
FIRST IS IT WOULD IT- AND- MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND CLARIFY HOW
MUCH THE FUNDING IS GOING FOR
THE EXPERIMENT STATIONS. AT THE%
MOMENT THERE IS A LOT LESS
INFORMATION AVAILABLE OF. THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE EXPERIMENT
STATIONS BUDGET RELATIVE TO THE-
MUCH MORE CONSIDERABLE
INFORMATION AVAILABLE ON YOU SEE
AN ARTS BUDGET. WE THINK WE'RE
GOING FORWARD THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD HAVE- JUST BETTER CLARITY
AS TO HOW MUCH FUNDING IS
PROVIDING FOR THE PROGRAM. THE
REASON IS WE THINK WOULD ALLOW A
LITTLE BIT MORE CONSISTENCY IN
HOW THE PROGRAMS ARE BUDGETED-
CURRENTLY THE PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
TREATED A LITTLE. SOMEWHAT
DIFFERENTLY IN TERMS OF THEIR OF
A BUDGETS. UNTIL RECENTLY
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION AND THE
FACT OF WHERE YOU SEE A AND R'S
STATE FUNDING HAD BEEN. SOMEWHAT
FLAT AND ACT AND THE DURING THE
PANDEMIC WAS ACTUALLY PRODUCED
BY THE STATE- AS AS- THE CHAIR
NOTED- THAT BLASTERS BUDGET-
REPLACE OF THAT REDUCTION AND
PROVIDED A- NONTRADITIONAL
AUGMENTATION TO HIRE MORE STAFF
. BUT COMPARISON THE EXPERIMENT
STATION PROGRAM HAS RECEIVED A
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENTS EACH
YEAR IN THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
AND ACCORDING TO THE UNIVERSITY
WAS LARGELY PRODUCTIVE FROM
ADOPTIONS DURING THE PANDEMIC.
THERE DOESN'T SEEM TO BE A CLEAR
BOB POLICY RATIONALE FOR THIS
DIFFERENCE IN TREATMENT IT'S
BASICALLY REFLECTING CAN YOU SEE
THE CURRENT BUDGET PRACTICES. WE
THINK I KEEPING OF THE FUNDS
TOGETHER WOULD ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE TO LOOK MORE
HOLISTICALLY AT BOTH PROGRAMS
AND CONSIDER FUNDING FOR BOTH
PROGRAMS NEED MOVING FORWARD AND
HOW WAS YOUR WAY THE TRADEOFFS
OF THE FUNDING MORE RESEARCH.
VERSUS APPLIED RESEARCH NOT
REACH. I'M SURE THAT YOU
RECOMMEND ARE REALLY AROUND JUST
ADDING MORE ACCORDING THE AIM OF
IMPROVING- THE LEGISLATURE'S
ABILITY TO BUDGET. FOR THESE
PROGRAMS AND MOVING FORWARD. AS
YOUR AGENDA NOTES THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET DOESN'T PROPOSE A CALL UP
FOR. YOU SEE A R. AND REALLY
BECAUSE THE LEGISLATURE ISN'T
GETTING IS A REGULAR REPORTING
ON ITS PROJECTED COST PRESSURES
AND AVAILABLE NONSTATE FUNDS TO
OFFSET SOME OF THOSE COST
PRESSURES. THE LEGISLATURE
REALLY HAS VERY WILL BE SAYS TO
ADJUST ITS BUDGET MOVING FORWARD
TO GETTING SOME MORE RECORDING
UP FRONT ON ITS BUDGET. AS WELL
AS SOME ADDITIONAL REPORTING ON
ITS OUTCOMES COULD YOU KNOW HELP
INFORM LEGISLATIVE DECISIONS
WITH THE BALL. HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THEN WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO-
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU BRIAN RELIGIOUS DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THE ADMINISTRATION
DOESN'T HAVE MORE TO ADD IN
TERMS OF UPDATING BUT WILL NOTE
THAT WE RECOGNIZE IT. AND
APPRECIATE THE IMPACT OF YOU
SEEN ARE INCLUDING THE FACT THAT
IT'S VERY BROAD. CROSS THE
STREET. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT. NINETY I CAN'T
TELL WHO'S COMMENTING I THINK
THERE IS A WAY INTO THE FUTURE
IS AN EMPLOYEE OF UCLA AND ALL.
WHO WHOEVER IT IS A- WELL LET ME
MOVE THROUGH SOME QUESTIONS
QUICKLY HERE AND- BOB LET ME
ASK- MRS VIRTON AND A GRATUITOUS
QUESTION OUT OF LAST YEAR
BECAUSE LAST YEAR WE GOT TO
POINT TO WHERE I ASKED THAT
EVERY DOLLAR WE APPROPRIATED FOR
THIS WAS GONNA GO TO THIS
PURPOSES IS THAT ACTUALLY.
HAPPENING NOW THAT WERE A YEAR
AND- THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
CENTER LAYERED- YES. ANR IS
GETTING ALL OF THE MONEY THAT
WAS APPROPRIATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THEM. FOR THE
PURPOSE SAYS- THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY DISCUSSED THANK YOU
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BURYING
WITH ME ON THAT QUESTION. AND
LET ME ASK A OF A- OF VICE
PRESIDENT HONEST AND- ONE
QUESTION ARE YOU ACTUALLY
PRESUME TO QUESTION OF MINE TO
LINE OUT HOW MANY POSITIONS IN
BED FILLED HOW MANY RECRUITMENT.
HOW MANY ARE GOING TO
RECRUITMENT THAT'S REALLY
HELPFUL AND IT IS THOSE NUMBERS
THAT OVER TIME WE WILL BE VERY
INTERESTED IN. AND I KNOW THIS
FROM ONE OF THE LOCAL ONES IN MY
DISTRICT. TO THE NUMBERS THAT
YOU OUTLINED COVER FILLING IN
FOR RETIREMENTS SO WE'RE NOT
JUST. FILLING THE NEEDS WERE MET
BEFORE FILLING BEHIND PEOPLE
THAT MIGHT. BE RETIRING IN THE
MIDDLE OF ALL THIS. SO AS WE
FORWARD TO- AND THERE ARE
RETIREMENTS THE SALARY SAVINGS
FROM THOSE RETIREMENTS WILL GO
INTO- OUR OUR ACADEMIC REVERSION
POOL. AND TO THE DEGREE WE CAN-
WE WILL HIRE WE DO UTILIZE OUR
POSITION CALL HOWEVER TO MAKE
SURE THAT AS WE HIRE WORKERS WE
ARE STAYING WITH WHAT ARE THE
CURRENT AND FUTURE NEEDS. ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES OF AN
ORGANIZATION WHERE YOU HAVE
FOLKS THAT WORK WITH US TWENTY
THIRTY EVEN FORTY YEARS WHEN WE
HAVE SOME FOLKS THAT LONG. IS
THAT- IN A CHANGING SITUATION
SUCH AS CALIFORNIA. SOMEBODY
WHO'S BEEN WORKING ON A CROP IN
ONE COUNTY FOR FORTY YEARS IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT CROSSES AND EVEN
GROWN IN THAT COUNTY ANYMORE. SO
THAT'S WHY WE DO OUR POSITION
CALL PROCESS AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE SERVING FOR TODAY'S AND
TOMORROW'S NEEDS TO HAVE IT AND
LET ME SAY I TOTALLY APPRECIATE
THAT THAT MAKES TOTAL SENSE I
SUPPORT THAT. I JUST KNOW THAT
IN ONE OF THE COUNTIES IN MY
DISTRICT. ARE ARE THEY HAVE A
NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES AND ALL BUT
TWO WERE RETIREMENT AGE AND SO
THEY WERE FREAKING OUT DID THAT
THOSE POSITIONS WON'T BE FILLED.
AND IF IT TURNS OUT THAT A CROP
ISN'T GROWN ANYMORE AND
SOMEBODY'S ROTATED OUT FOR THAT
TOTALLY UNDERSTANDABLE I THINK
IT'S JUST MAKING SURE THAT
THERE'S- THERE'S STILL ONE
BEHIND IN THE MIDST OF THIS. AND
THEN LET ME ASK A QUESTION A
FINANCE. FIRM ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT. THAT WE DID THIS
RESTORATION LAST YEAR. WAS IT
WAS AS DALY- JUST SAID THERE
WERE A NUMBER OF YEARS IN WHICH
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM WAS
FLAT. AND THEN LO AND BEHOLD. OF
THIS YEAR FINANCE DID NOT
PROPOSE A COLA A AND I CAN
IMAGINE THAT IT'S AN EXPECTATION
THAT THE MONEY WOULD BE FULLY
SPENT BUT- IT SEEMS TO ME LIKE
IT'S A REAL PRECEDENT OR COULD
WE JUST NOT FALL BEHIND AGAIN
AND- SO. NOW THAT I'VE STATED A
VERY FIRM A PEN AND PUSHED YOU
INTO THE CORNER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO MAKE A COMMENT. I WANT TO
CHURCH A YOU. SO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET DOES NOT INCLUDE A COLA
FOR YOU SEE IN OUR- THAT'S
THAT'S WHERE WE STAND RIGHT NOW.
OKAY MORE THAN I WILL SAY I
STAND DIFFERENTLY SO I HOPE BY
THE TIME WE GET TO THE MARKET
MAY REVISE YOU CAN FIGURE OUT A
CALL US SO WE JUST DON'T FALL
BEHIND ONCE AGAIN AND EVEN IF.
IT TURNS OUT THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO SPEND ALL OF THIS YEAR'S
MONEY BECAUSE IT TAKES SO LONG
TO RECRUIT AND GET COMPLETELY OP
I WOULD NOT WANT TO LOSE TO THE
GAIN AND PURCHASING POWER
PARTICULARLY SINCE WE HAVE
INFLATION AGAIN SO I JUST HOPE
THAT A CALL WILL BE REFLECTED IN
THE- IN THE MAY REVISED AND NOT
LET ME GO TO THE ONE ISSUE OF
THE HOUR THAT THAT- CAME OUT OF
THE L. A- OFF. OF- REPORT. AND
THAT'S THE- FIRM. THERE THERE'S
THE ISSUE OF THE AGRICULTURAL
STATIONS AND AS I UNDERSTAND
THEY REPORT DIRECTLY. TO THE
PRESIDENT IN THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT AND THEN WE HAVE.
COOPER VEGAS TENSION WHICH WE'VE
JUST BEEN DISCUSSING THAT IS
WITH WITH IN. UC ANR- IN LET ME
S. C. L. A. O. Y. U. OF
RECOMMENDED- ARMS MOVING THE
AGRICULTURAL STATE OF STATIONS
TO AND ARE. YOUR RECOMMENDATION
ISN'T NECESSARILY TO CHANGE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE STRUCTURE OF AN
R. OR THE EXPERIMENT STATIONS
FOR KIDS BY CHANGE THE
LEADERSHIP OF IT IT'S TO ARE
CATEGORICALLY- PROVIDE FUNDING
FOR THE EXPERIMENT STATIONS.
LIKE IT DOES FOR A AND ARE SO
YOU KNOW THAT COULD LOOK LIKE- A
SPECIFIC LINE ITEM IN THE BUDGET
WITH A SCHEDULE ONE DAY NOTING
FUNDS FOR COOPER MAKES CENTURY
C. A. R. AND ANOTHER DENOTING
FUNDS FOR EXPERIMENT STATIONS.
AND SO IT OUR OUR RIGHT HERE IS
MORE AROUND- CLARIFYING THE
MODESTY FUNDING THAT'S GONG TO
THE EXPERIMENT STATIONS. KIND OF
ADDRESSING SOME OF THE LIMITED
INFORMATION WHAT THE STATE HAS
ON EXPERIMENT STATIONS RELATIVE
TO YOU SEE A IN OUR- AND THEN
ALSO. OF ALLOWING FOR SOME MORE
CONSISTENT- BUDGETING MOVING
FORWARD ENSURING THAT IF ONE
PROGRAM'S GETTING LOCAL- THE
OTHER PROGRAM IS OR IF. IF
THEY'RE NOT GETTING THE SAME
AUGMENTATION THERE SORT OF OUR
RATIONALE BEHIND IT IS. JUST ARE
REFLECTING- YOU SEE BUDGET
PRACTICES THAT DON'T APPEAR TO
HAVE A CLEAR POLICY BASIS. THANK
YOU NOW LET ME ASK OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO
COMMENT ON THAT AND FRANKLY. I
HATE TO DO THIS TO YOU- SAY-
BUT- I THINK THIS IS AT A
SLIGHTLY HIGHER PAY GRADE THAT
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF. A AND R.
BECAUSE IT'S A DECISIONS
PROBABLY ORGANIZATIONAL THAT
WOULD BE MADE WITHIN UC. YOUR DO
YOU HAVE A COMMENT IN RESPONSE.
TO THE L. A. O.'S RECOMMENDATION
. I THINK I WILL TURN THIS ONE
OVER TO VICE PRESIDENT YOU MUST
IN PLACE. OKAY BUT SHE CAN'T SAY
IT'S ABOVE HER PAY GRADE. OKAY
MADAM VICE PRESIDENT OVER TO YOU
. YES WE APPRECIATE THE L. A.
ELSE TIME AND ATTENTION TO
LOOKING AT OUR PROGRAMS AND THE
REPORT OF THE UC SYSTEM IS NOT
IN SUPPORT OF MOVING THE A YES
BUDGET INTO THE A AND R. LINE
ITEM AND THIS IS LARGELY BECAUSE
WE HAVE FOUND THAT EACH CAMPUS
ITSELF IS BEST POSITIONED TO
UNDERSTAND ITS BASIC COMPLIED
RESEARCH CONTINUE ON. BASED UPON
THAT CAMPUS IS SPECIFIC
INFRASTRUCTURE AND PERSONNEL
STRENGTHS- REALLY FOR THE
CONTINUING TO WORK WHILE THE AG
EXPERIMENT STATION SCIENTISTS
COLLABORATE VERY CLOSELY WITH
OTHER SCIENTISTS ON THAT CAMPUS
AND THE CAMPUS CAN BEST ORGANIZE
THAT BUT WE ARE VERY OPEN TO
WORKING WITH THE L. A. ON THE
COMMITTEE ON OTHER SOLUTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND JUST
BEFORE WE MOVE OFF OF THAT TOPIC
SIR ANYBODY ELSE THAT WISHES TO
COMMENT ON THAT IT DIDN'T
COMMENT YET. OR WISHES TO
COMMENT. SEEING NO ONE LET ME
ASK US SENATE ROADSHOW BOGUE SHE
HAS NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS AND
SO LET ME SAY A BEFORE WE LEAVE
THIS ITEM THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S
PARTICIPATION TODAY I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE PROGRESS THAT IS
BEING MADE ON THIS AND I THINK
IT IS REALLY WELL REGARDED
ACROSS THE STATE- D. IN THIS
BUSINESS YOU DIDN'T. USE YOU
DON'T ALWAYS GET THANKED FOR
THINGS AND WHEN I RETURNED FROM
THE SUMMER RECESS LAST YEAR DOOR
HUGE STACK OF THANK YOU CARDS ON
MY DESK FOR WHAT WE DID WITH YOU
SEE AN ART LAST YEAR AND SO-
HOPE THAT THIRD CALL ISSUES
ADDRESSED WE DON'T WANT TO LOSE.
LOOSE PACE I HOPE WE CONTINUE TO
MOVE A PATIENT FILLING THOSE
POSITIONS AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING THE CONTINUED REPORTS ON
THE PROGRESS AND I THANK
EVERYBODY FOR- PARTICIPATING
TODAY. OR WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
OUR AS YOU NUMBER SIX
IMPLEMENTATION OF PREVIOUS
BUDGET ACT AGREEMENTS IT'S AN
OVERSIGHT ITEM. AND THE ONLY-
PANELIST IS A SAY A FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA LET ME
RECOGNIZE HER RIGHT NOW. THANK
YOU CHAIR LAYERED. THE COMMITTEE
AGENDA OUTLINES MULTIPLE ISSUES
RELATED BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. I'M GOING TO TOUCH
ON EACH OF THESE BRIEFLY IN THE
ORDER THAT THEY APPEAR ON YOUR
AGENDA. PLEASE FULLER ME IF YOU
WOULD LIKE ME TO SKIP AHEAD AT
ANY TIME. BEGINNING WITH YOU SEE
I JUST HAVE TO SAY WE ARE ALL
RUNNING REALLY SHORT ON TIME AND
WANT TO ALLOW SOME TIME FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT SO. WHAT WE DO
THIS IF YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO
ADD. ON YOUR POSITION THAT'S IN
THE AGENDA REPORT WANTED TO DO
THAT AND OTHERWISE. I WILL JUST
MOVE DIRECTLY TO QUESTIONS. THIS
VERY QUICKLY ON- NEW C. O. P. E.
R. FUNDING HAVING RETURNED TO
THE CAMPUS ASSESSMENT. NOT ONLY
IS THE TOTAL YOU SEE OP BUDGET
FOR TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
WITH THE SAME AS IT WAS IN
NINETEEN TWENTY. BUT FOR TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO. TWENTY NINETEEN
AND TWENTY TWENTY NOT THE YEAR
NINETEEN TWENTY RIGHT. JUST
CHECK THIRTY. HERE TWENTY NINE
STUDENTS NOT KEEPING UP WITH
INFLATION. WE WOULD BE TROUBLE-
THE REGENTS HAVE A TOTAL CAMPUS
THAT MATCHES THE STATE LINE ITEM
THANK YOU SEE OP HAD IN THE.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET
OF. THE UC WE BUDGET TODAY IS
NOT THE UC OP BUDGET OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN IMPORTANT CHANGES TO
TRANSPARENCY DOCUMENTATION AND
DECISION MAKING HAVE ÒN
THESE REFORMS INCLUDE THE
FORMATION OF THE EXECUTIVE
BUDGET COMMITTEE COMPOSED OF
CHANCELLORS VICE CHANCELLORS OF
FINANCE AND OTHER CAMPUS LEADERS
WHO REVIEW YOU C. O. P.
EXPENDITURES AND PROVIDE
GUIDANCE FOR THE PRESIDENT ON
THE UC OP PROGRAMS AND
EXPENDITURES. IN ADDITION YOU
SEE OP HAS DEVELOPED A DOCTOR
AND DOCUMENTED RESEARCH POLICY
AND RESERVES ARE NOT REPORTED
QUARTERLY TO THE UC REGENTS
ALONG WITH THE BUDGET AND
AMOUNTS TO ACTUAL EXPENDITURES.
YOU C. O. P. IMPLEMENTED AND
ENTIRE NEW BUDGET AND PLANNING
SYSTEM COMPLETED A COMPREHENSIVE
REVIEW OF EACH YOU SEE OP FUND
AND ITS USE THERE WAS ALSO AN
EXPENSIVE PROCESS TO DOCUMENT
EACH PROGRAM AN INITIATIVE AND
PROVIDE CLEAR DEFINITIONS OF
EACH. THE UC CHANCELLORS
REQUESTED THE RETURN TO THE
CAMPUS ASSESSMENT AND THEY
DECIDE FOR THEIR CAMPUS WHICH
FUNDING SOURCES THEY WILL USE TO
PAY THE ASSESSMENT THE CAMPUSES
WILL REPORT ON THE FUNDING
SOURCES THEY USED FOR THE
ASSESSMENT AFTER THE FISCAL YEAR
BOOKS ARE CLOSED. THE UC REGENTS
WILL APPROVE A PRELIMINARY
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE IT WAS
STILL BE BUDGET AD MAKE THE
REGION'S WILL ACCRUE PROGRAIS
FINAL USED TO BE BUDGET IN JULY-
DUMP WILL REFLECT ANY
LEGISLATIVE ACTIONS. ON THE UC
OF THE BUDGET. AND THEN THIS.
BEFORE WERE. TO VERY QUICKLY ON
THE PROGRAM- I WANTEDTO LET YOU
KNOW THAT WE ARE ESTABLISHING
THE TWO NEW PRIME PROGRAMS
FOCUSED ON THE NEEDS OF THE
AMERICAN INDIAN THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES. AND THE
BLACK AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA. OVER
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS PRIME WILL
EXPAND TO NEARLY FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS SYSTEM WIDE. UP WE
RECEIVED THE TWELVE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE PRIME
PROGRAM AFTER THE- ADMISSIONS
PROCESS FOR THE CURRENT YEAR HAD
ALREADY CLOSED SO THE NEXT
COHORT WILL BE ADMITTED THIS
SPRING WILL START WITH THESE
FUNDS. ON THE EMERGENCY
FINANCIAL AID I WANT TO THANK
THE LEGISLATURE FOR PROVIDING
THESE FUNDS FOR YOU SEE STUDENTS
WE HAD MANY STUDENTS WHO HAD
THEIR INCOME OR THEIR FAMILY'S
INCOME IMPACTED DURING COED-
THIS IS ARE INFLUENCED BY A
FEDERAL ACTION IS WEALTHY
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN ACT PASSED
IN MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THEY ARE BY INCLUDED ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR MILLION AND
EMERGENCY STUDENT FINANCIAL AID
FOR UC'S STUDENTS. THEY ARE ALSO
HAD A REQUIREMENT THAT ALL THE
FUNDS HAD TO BE SPENT WITHIN
TWELVE MONTHS OR ANY UNEXPECTED
BALANCES WOULD HAVE TO BE
RETURNED TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AFTER THE PASSAGE OF
THE ACT UC CAMPUSES PRIMARILY
PROVIDED ARBOR FUNDS AS
EMERGENCY FINANCIAL AID TO
STUDENTS. CAMPUSES WILL MAKE AN
APPLICATION FOR STATE EMERGENCY
FINANCIAL AID AVAILABLE FOR TO
STUDENTS IN SPRING QUARTER AND
BEYOND UNTIL THE FIFTEEN MILLION
HAS BEEN ALLOCATED OUT TO
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS. AND ON THE
DUAL ADMISSIONS PATHWAY I WANTED
TO MENTION THAT- WE WILL BEGIN
ADMISSIONS TO END OF THIS
PROGRAM- DURING THE SPRING OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AS REQUIRED
BY THE PASSED AUTHORIZING
LEGISLATION AB ONE THIRTY TWO.
BUDGET TRAILER BILL OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THIS PROGRAM WILL
FOCUS ON THOSE STUDENTS WHO
APPLY TO YOU SEE WHO HAVE THE
MINIMUM HIGH SCHOOL GPA OF THREE
POINT OH BUT WHO HAVE NOT
FULFILLED NECESSARY A THROUGH G.
REQUIREMENTS FOR ADMISSIONS. IN
THE ADMISSIONS CYCLE OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ABOUT THREE THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED STUDENTS WITH HIGH
SCHOOL GPAS OF THREE POINT OH OR
ABOVE APPLY TO YOU SEE WHO HAD
NOT COMPLETED A THROUGH G. ABOUT
HALF OF THOSE APPLICANTS.
IDENTIFIED AS A MEMBER OF AN
UNDER REPRESENTED GROUP. AND SO
IT IS THOSE STUDENTS WHO HAVE
THAT- GPA BUT NOT THE A THROUGH
G. COURSES THAT THIS PROGRAM
WILL FOCUS ON. AND WE'LL HAVE
MORE TO REPORT TO YOU AND FUTURE
YEARS- THE CAL ISI'S WERE
PROVIDED WITH ABOUT TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS OVER FIVE YEARS
IN THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND THAT IS ACRONYM
MEANS INSTITUTES FOR SCIENCE AND
INNOVATION IS THAT CORRECT. THAT
IS CORRECT SIR CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTES ON SCIENCE AND
INNOVATION- I SHOULD HAVE TAKEN
NOTE OF YOUR YOUR NOTES TO CHASE
AND BUT I DIDN'T WANT MY
COMPUTER TO FREE. SO I HAD TO
SKIP OVER EXPLAINING
ORGANIZATION AT THE- BUT THE
FUNDS WILL USED TO CREATE A
ENTER AND FELL EXPERI WHERE
STUDENTS WILL WORK IN SMALL
TEAMS WITH A MENTOR TO CONDUCT
RESEARCH- AND WORK WITH A
COMPANY THAT WILL PROVIDE
MATCHING FUNDS- AND DO AND
ENTERPRENEURS EFFORTS- THESE
OPPORTUNITIES INCLUDE IMMERSIVE
SUMMER EXPERIENCES NEAR ALONG
MENTOR INTERNSHIPS AND A TWO
WEEK INTENSIVE CREATOR WORKSHOP.
WHICH IS PLANNED LATER TO BE
DEVELOPED INTO CONTINUING
EDUCATION CERTIFICATES- THEIR
CALLOUS I ASIDE ARE
COLLABORATING ACROSS CAMPUSES
WITH MERCED RIVERSIDE IN SANTA
CRUZ STUDENTS PARTICIPATING IN
INTERNSHIP OPPORTUNITIES AS WELL
SO WE ARE TAKING CARE TO SET UP.
OPPORTUNITIES NEAR THOSE
CAMPUSES SO ALL STUDENTS CAN CAN
PARTICIPATE. AND MOVING ON TO SB
EIGHT TWENTY THANK YOU SEE
EMPLOYMENT AND CAPITAL OUTLAY-
SB EIGHT TWENTY WAS A BUDGET
TRAILER BILL OF TWENTY TWENTY
REQUIRING TO UNIVERSITY TO
CERTIFY THAT ALL CLEANING
MAINTENANCE GROUNDS KEEPING FOOD
SERVICE OR OTHER WORK
TRADITIONALLY PERFORMED BY
PERSONS WITH UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SERVICE UNIT S. X.
JOB CLASSIFICATIONS. SHALL BE
PERFORMED ONLY FROM PLEASE OF
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AT
EACH FACILITY IN WHICH THERE HAS
BEEN A STATE FUNDED CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECT. THE UNIVERSITY
WAS ALSO REQUIRED TO CERTIFY
RETROACTIVELY TO JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THAT THE WORK
DESCRIBED ABOVE HAD BEEN
PERFORMED EXCLUSIVELY BY
EMPLOYEES AND THEY ASKED ME
ASPECTS BARGAINING UNIT AT ALL
TIMES SINCETHE UNIVERSITY
RECEIVED STATE FUNDING FOR
CAPITAL OUTLAY EXPENDITURE. OR
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECT.
UNIVERSITY OF PER. A
CERTIFICATION THE LEGISLATURE ON
JUNE ELEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND A SUPPLEMENTAL CERTIFICATION
ON SEPTEMBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. UNDER THE S. B. A. TWENTY
REQUIREMENTS SIX UC LOCATION
CERTIFIED THAT THERE ARE NO
EXCEPTIONS UNDER STATUTE FROM
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THROUGH THE END
OF THE FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THOSE WERE C DAVIS
UC IRVINE UC RIVERSIDE UC SAN
DIEGO LAWRENCE BERKELEY NATIONAL
LABORATORY AND THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT. LOCATIONS THAT NOTED
SEVERAL INSTANCES WHERE
CONTRACTED SERVICES WERE USED
IMPOSSIBILITIES THAT HAD
RECEIVED STATE CAPITAL OUTLAY
FUNDING SINCE JANUARY TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. FOR UC BERKELEY UCLA
UC MERCED UC SANTA BARBARA UC
SANTA CRUZ UC SAN FRANCISCO AND
UC AGRICULTUREAND NATURAL
RESOURCES. THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THE NON COMPLIANT CONTRACTS WERE
REPORTED AS CLOSED. IT IN THAT
LOCATION HAD ALREADY STOPPED
USING THIRD PARTY CONTRACTORS TO
PERFORM THE SERVICES WITH THE
WORK BEING SUBSEQUENTLY
PERFORMED BY UNIVERSITY
EMPLOYEES. HI SEPTEMBER FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO YEARS HE PLANS
TO SUBMIT UPDATED CERTIFICATIONS
FOR ALL FACILITIES WITH
COMPLETED PROJECTS THROUGH THE
END OF FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. AND JUST A NOTE ON
THE BILL CO COURT PROGRAM
EXTENSION- THIS PROGRAM WAS
CREATED IN TWENTY TEN- BY AB
FIFTY TWO BY CENTER PORTANTINO.
OF IT CHARGES A TWO DOLLAR FEE
ON BIRTH CERTIFICATE COPIES AND
HAS AN ANNUAL BUDGET OF ABOUT
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION. THERE IS
A BUDGET. SORRY THERE'S A POLICY
BILL THAT HAS BEEN RECENTLY
INTRODUCED SB EIGHT EIGHT THREE
BY CENTER SPROSTON PORTANTINO.
THAT WOULD EXTEND THIS PROGRAM
TO TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN- A FEW
HIGHLIGHTS OF THE PROGRAM ARE
DEAD AFTER A BABY IS BORN.BLOOD
IS COLLECTED FROM THE UMBILICAL
CORD AND PLACENTA NOPE BLOOD IS
EVER TAKEN FROM THE BABY AND NO
EMBRYOS. ARE INVOLVED IN THIS
PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM
FACILITATES THE COLLECTION OF
BETWEEN FIVE AND SIX THOUSAND
UNIT COURTS OF BLOOD EACH YEAR
OF WHICH ABOUT FIVE TO TEN
PERCENT. OF OUR OF THE CONDITION
THAT THEY CAN BE BANKED- FROM
DAYS BLOOD COURTS STEM CELL
TRANSPLANTS CAN BE PROVIDED TO
RECIPIENTS. BUT THESE TRANSPLANT
. IT'S PLANTS MUST MATCH THE
TRANSPLANT PATIENT AT SPECIFIC
GENES THAT CAN BE INFLUENCED BY
RACIAL AND ETHNIC ANCESTRY. THE
RARER PATIENTS ANCESTRY TO MORE
DIFFICULT IT CAN BE TO FIND AN
APPROPRIATELY MATCH SUITABLE
LIVING DONOR. THESE BLOOD CHORDS
CAN BE USED TO TREAT OVER EIGHTY
DISEASES INCLUDING LEUKEMIA
LYMPHOMAS AND INHERITED IMMUNE
SYSTEM DISORDERS. I HAD AN EIGHT
WITH WE ARE JUST REALLY RUNNING
LATE AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THAT WAS THE LAST ITEM SO THAT
WAS THE LAST DAY AND I ONLY HAD
ONE QUESTION AND WAS ON THAT
ITEM. OF BECAUSE YOU MENTIONED
THAT A POLICY BILL BEEN
INTRODUCED BUT I THINK IT'S THE
PREFERENCE OF THE AUTHORED THAT
IT BE DONE THROUGH THE BUDGET
AND THE BUDGET ACT OF REQUIRED
TO REPORT BY JANUARY FIRST AND I
WAS WONDERING IF THAT REPORTED
BEEN SUBMITTED. I WAS TOLD
PRIVATE WE HADN'T BEEN BUT MAYBE
YOU KNOW HAS IT BEEN SUBMITTED
ALREADY. I BELIEVE THE REPORT
HAS BEEN SUBMITTED AND I WILL
GET YOU A COPY OF THAT GREAT I
WILL I WILL GET EVERY COMMITTEE
MEMBER A COPY OF THAT BECAUSE
HOPEFULLY FINANCES LISTENING.
THIS WOULD BE THE IDEAL PLACE TO
JUST EXTEND TO SUNSET BASED ON
THE REPORT IF THE REPORT SHOWS
THAT THE PROGRAM IS DOING WHAT
IT INTENDED. BUT OUR- YOU KNOW
WE COULD BE GOOD TO GET A COPY
OF THAT REPORT AND NO AND JUST
HOPEFULLY EVERYBODY'S LISTENING
AND TRY TO FIGURE THAT OUT. LET
ME ASK A SENATOR OTRO BLOQUE
CENTER MEN HAD NO QUESTIONS ON
THE SIDE OF DID YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS I THINK BY QUESTION
WAS- SIMILAR TO YOURS BUT I DO
HAVE A QUESTION- I THIS IS THE-
I WAS A- THIS IS A NEW PROGRAM I
WAS NOT AWARE THAT THIS EXISTED
IN CALIFORNIA. AND I'M JUST KIND
OF CURIOUS. IS THIS WHAT THE
AWARENESS OF PARENTS ARE OF THE
MOTHERS GIVING BIRTH. IT IS WITH
THE PERMISSION OF THE MOTHERS
GIVING BIRTH OR IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT CALIFORNIA DOES
AUTOMATICALLY. I THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION SENATOR- THIS IS A
VOLUNTARY PROGRAM. WHERE THE
PARENTS OF THE BABY. MUST
PROVIDE PERMISSION TO HAVE THE
BLOOD COLLECTED. PERFECT THANK
YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION. THANK
YOU THAT COMPLETES OF THIS ITEM
I APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S SUPPORT
DISSIPATION WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
OUR LAST ITEM ISSUE SEVEN
STUDENT HOUSING ARE WITH SAY HA
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SO WELCOME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ON THE SIDE OF.
THANK YOU CHIRLA OR IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I WILL TRY TO
MOVE FAST. UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZES THAT
AFFORDABLE STUDENT HOUSING IS
NECESSARY FOR CONTAINING THE
TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE AND
THAT MAKING FOR AFFORDABLE SAFE
AND CONVENIENT HOUSING AVAILABLE
FOR STUDENTS. IS NECESSARY TO
REACH OUR GOAL OF DEBT FREE
EDUCATION IN TWENTY FIFTEEN THE
UNIVERSITY STARTED THE STUDENT
HOUSING INITIATIVE TO EXPAND
AVAILABLE CAMPUS HOUSING SINCE
THAT TIME CAMPUSES HAVE
COMPLETED. BETWEEN FALL TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND FALL TWENTY
TWENTY SIX ANOTHER TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND STUDENT HOUSING BEDS
ARE PLANNED. THESE NEWUNITS ARE
PLANNED TO BE 10220% BELOW
MARKET RATE IN THEIR RESPECTIVE
COMMUNITIES. STATUTE SPECIFIES
THAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA WILL RECEIVE 20% OF
THE HIGHER EDUCATION STUDENT
HOUSING GRANT PROGRAM FUNDS.
THIS WOULD MEAN THE UNIVERSITY
COULD RECEIVE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION OF THE TOTAL TWO BILLION
PROGRAM. ACCORDING TO STATUTE
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WILL
NOTIFY THE LEGISLATURE ON MARCH
FIRST WHICH PROJECTS WILL
RECEIVE FUNDING IN THE FIRST
YEAR OF THE PROGRAM. FOR THE
FIRST ROUND OF FUNDING FROM
WHICH THE UNIVERSITY ANTICIPATES
RECEIVING ONE HUNDRED MILLION OF
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
AVAILABLE UC CAMPUSES SUBMITTED
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED MILLION IN
STATE FUNDING REQUEST. IF
APPROVED THIS REQUEST WOULD
COMPLETE TWO THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED NEW STATE FUNDED BEDS AS
PART OF LARGER PROJECTS THAT
WOULD ADD OVER FOUR THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED NEW STUDENT BEDS
IN TOTAL. SO THROUGH THE PROCESS
OF EXPANDING STUDENT HOUSING THE
UNIVERSITY HAS LEARNED THAT
STUDENTS WANT TO LIVE IN CAMPUS
HOUSING THE PROXIMITY TO CLASSES
IN CAMPUS SERVICES RELIABLE RENT
AND KARATE REQUEST FEARS. MEANS
THAT AS SOON AS THE PROJECT IS
COMPLETED IT HAS BEEN FULLY
OCCUPIED WITH STUDENTS. WE HAVE
SEEN THAT IT IS VERY DIFFICULT
TO GUARANTEE STUDENT HOUSING
THAT IS FAR BELOW MARKET RATE.
CURRENTLY UC CAMPUS HOUSING IS
OFFERED UP 220% BELOW MARKET
RATE RESTRICTIONS ON RENT BASED
INCOME OF NEARBY STUDENT. NON
STUDENT POPULATION DOES NOT MAKE
MUCH SENSE TO THE STUDENTS
HAVING UNIQUE TEMPORARY ECONOMIC
CIRCUMSTANCES IF THIS PROGRAM IS
EXPANDED BEYOND THE CURRENT TWO
BILLION. WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH YOU ON HOW
RENT COULD BE CALCULATED SO AS
TO MINIMIZE STUDENT COSTS WHILE
ACKNOWLEDGING THE REALITIES OF
THE CONSTRUCTION MARKET. IN
TWENTY TWENTY UC CAMPUSES WERE
HOUSING ABOUT HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS OR 87% OF THE
STUDENT POPULATION. SOME OF OUR
CAMPUSES WOULD LIKE THE HOUSE
HALF OF THEIR STUDENT
POPULATIONS. AS TO UNIVERSITY
INCREASES OUR UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENT POPULATION BY ANOTHER 1%
ANNUALLY AND AS WE INCREASE
GRADUATE STUDENT ENROLLMENT WE
WILL NEED MORE HOUSING TO ENSURE
WE CONTINUE TO MAKE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AVAILABLE
FOR OUR STUDENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND LET ME JUST CUT TO
THE CHASE WITH A QUESTION- THE
OF. LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR
LAST YEAR- DID TWO BILLION
DOLLARS FOR HIGHER EDUCATION
HOUSING OVER THREE YEARS FOR ALL
THREE BRANCHES. N. IT'S MY UNDER
IT AND WE TALKED ABOUT THIS AT
THE CSU HEARING- LAST WEEK WE
WILL TALK ABOUT THIS AT A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE HEARING NEXT
WEEK A. N. IT IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT IT'S JUST DRAMATICALLY
OVERSUBSCRIBED FROM THE START
SO. DID I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
UNIVERSITY HAS- AN AGGREGATE OF
SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
APPLICATIONS THAT ARE IN IN THIS
FIRST ROUND. THAT IS CORRECT-
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
QUALIFIES FOR FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION OF THE TOTAL PROGRAM AND
WE HAVE ALREADY SUBMITTED SIX
HUNDRED MILLION WORTH OF
PROJECTS AND DOES THAT MEAN THAT
YOUR PRIORITIZING TO GET TO THE
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION WHO ARE
EXPECTING THE STATE TO DO THAT
AND HOW THE APPLICATIONS COME.
WE ARE ANTICIPATING THE STATE
THE SELECT WHICH PROGRAMS WHICH
PROJECTS THEY WANT TO FIND- AND
SHOULD THERE BE MORE FUNDING
MADE AVAILABLE HOPEFUL THAT
PERHAPS YOU CAN. FIND ALL OF
THOSE PROJECTS AND IF THIS IS
THE FIRST YEAR AND YOU HAVE SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOES THAT
PRESUME THE FACT THAT YOU WOULD
HAVE OTHER PROJECTS IN THE
SECOND AND THIRD YEAR. ROUTED
AS- AS THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
OPENS UP THE NEXT ROUND OF
APPLICATIONS WE WOULD ALLOW ANY
ADDITIONAL CAMPUSES TO APPLY FOR
THOSE FUNDS IF THEY WISH. AND
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THOUGH IS.
YOU'RE ALREADY AT THE ED IT IS A
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION IS FOR JUST
FOR THE FIRST YEAR THE CAP
PRODUCT. THE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION AS FOR THE TOTAL PROGRAM
ALL YEARS TOWER YOUR SAY SO
THEN. YOU HAVE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION FOR ALL THREE YEARS IN
THE FIRST YEAR YOU'VE APPLIED
FOR SIX HUNDRED MILLION AND YOU
JUST INDICATED THAT YOU WOULD
ALLOW CAMPUSES TO SUBMIT
APPLICATIONS FOR EVEN MORE IN
THE SECOND OR THIRD YEAR SET
CORRECT. THAT'S CORRECT WITH
THAT IS THAT BASICALLY TO
DEMONSTRATE THE NEED EVEN IF
IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT THERE'S
MONEY AVAILABLE. WHERE WE WANT
TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT OUR
CAMPUSES FEEL THAT THEY CAN THEY
CAN HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMPETE WE DON'T WANT TO TELL
THEM THEY CAN'T COMPETE BUT I
MEAN ARE YOU IF THE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION WAS GIVEN TO THE
UNIVERSITY. IN GRANTS IN THE
FIRST YEAR- AND THEN PEOPLE ARE
STILL APPLYING YOU'RE SAYING YOU
WANT THEM TO KNOW THEY CAN
COMPETE BUT THE MONEY WOULD HAVE
ALREADY BEEN SUBSCRIBE FOR THE
FULL UC PORTION FOR THE THREE
YEARS IS THAT CORRECT. THAT
THAT'S CORRECT IT IS IT IS IT
THAT JUST SEEMS LIKE A WEIRD
PROCESS. IT A. N. I'M NOT I
MEAN. IT'S YOUR ABILITY TO DO
WHATEVER YOU WANT BURKE BUT IT
SEEMS LIKE IT'S RAISING FALSE
HOPES IN LESS WE DO. WHAT I
WOULD HOPE WE WOULD DO IS FIGURE
OUT HOW TO APPROPRIATE
ADDITIONAL MONEY BECAUSE THEY
NEED TO SPEND DEMONSTRATE. THIS
IS SO- BUT I A N. DOT. N. I KNOW
THAT WITHIN THE SIX HUNDRED
MILLION. IT'S DIFFERENT CAMPUSES
IT'S WHERE IT SHOVEL READY I
KNOW HASTINGS'S IN THEIR FOR
THEIR MAJOR PROJECT AND THAT'S A
VERY SIGNIFICANT PROJECT FOR
THEM. AND SO- D. I. A. IN OUR-
YOU'RE LOOKING TENSE I THINK I
WOULD JUST MAKE THE STATEMENT
THAT ARM. THAT I AGREE FOR ONE
COMMITTEE MEMBER AND OTHERS CAN
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES THAT IT ALL
THINGS BEING EQUAL BE NICE IF WE
DID MORE FOR THIS OVER THE THREE
YEARS TO ACCOMMODATE THE NEEDS
THAT ACTUALLY EXISTS AND IT'S-
IF YOU'VE GOT SOME CAMPUSES
SAYING THEY DON'T WANT TO ADMIT
STUDENTS IN LEICESTER'S HOUSING
AND THEN. THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
GRANTS FOR HOUSING AND IF YOU
LOOK AT WHAT HAS CHANGED IN THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING MARKET IS
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO GET
HOUSING AND SOME. SOME CAMPUSES-
IN SUMMER IN THE CSU SYSTEM NOT
NOT JUST UC. ARE ARE HAVING
TROUBLE WITH PEOPLE FINDING A
PLACE TO LIVE AFTER ACCEPTANCE
AND IT'S JUST GETTING IN THE WAY
OF THEIR EDUCATION THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY A REAL ISSUE SO. I
THINK WITHOUT GOING BACK AND
FORTH ANYMORE I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT- THAT DID TO THE
ADMINISTRATION TO MY COLLEAGUES-
WE'RE JUST GONNA HAVE TO LOOK AT
MORE FOR THIS AND I DON'T KNOW
IF THAT'S GOING TO WORK. BUT
IT'S JUST SOMETHING WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO DO. OUR WHAT ME ASK-
CENTER BURKE CHAU BOAT IF THE
BOAT IF SHE HAS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON THE SIDE. I JUST
WHEN I ECHO YOUR YOUR CONCERNS
AND YOUR COMMENTS AT I
COMPLETELY AGREE. AT IT GOES
BACK TO MY EARLIER COMMENT ON.
THE REQUIREMENT THAT WE HAVE OF
OUR UNIVERSITIES ARE C. IS USED
IN OUR SPECIES TO. ADMIT MORE
STUDENTS BUT- WERE STATE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE ABLE TO
CATER. ONE CLASSES COURSE
AVAILABILITY TO HOUSING TO MAKE
IT MORE AFFORDABLE FOR OUR FOR
OUR STUDENTS. AND AND I WAS JUST
GONNA CAREERS IT CAUGHT MY
ATTENTION AS A FORMER REALTOR.
YOU'D MENTIONED THE STUDENT
HOUSING BEING BETWEEN TEN TO UP
220% BELOW THE MARKET LEVEL.
THAT'S STILL SEEMS VERY HIGH FOR
STUDENT HOUSING- ON THAT END SO-
I. WOULD ABSOLUTELY AGREE YOUR
YOUR COMMENTS TODAY THAT WE NEED
TO LOOK AT IT FURTHER-
ALLOCATION OF A FUNDING- ON THAT
ON THAT ASPECT BACK DOWN- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO
THE FUTURE CONVERSATIONS I THINK
YOU TO YOUR COMMENTS AND- THANK
YOU- TO SAY. FOR A PUTTING UP
WITH SEVEN. DIFFERENT ITEMS AND
WE HAVE MADE IT THROUGH. HOWEVER
WE ONLY HAVE ABOUT TWENTY
MINUTES UNTIL. FOUR WE HAVE TO
GERM AND SO- I'M- GOING TO GO TO
TESTIMONY BUT- I'M GONNA HAVE TO
DO IT A DIFFERENT WAY WHICH IS.
I THINK- ANYBODY THAT COMES ON
OR IS IN THE ROOM IS JUST GONNA
HAVE TO SAY THEIR NAME IN THE
ORGANIZATION. AND WHAT THEY'RE
FOR AGAINST IT JUST NO
EXPLANATION AND THEN WE'LL TRY
TO GET THROUGH AS MANY OF THEM
AS WE CAN. BEFORE FIVE TO TWELVE
AND BEFORE I GO TO THE MODERATOR
AND MODERATOR STAND BY. ME ASK
IS THERE ANYBODY IN THE HEARING
ROOM THAT WISHES. TO TESTIFIED
ANYONE. SAYING NO ONE. OF THE-
FEAR THEY'RE WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. IS THE MODERATOR
THERE SORRY FOR THE DELAY MISTER
CHAIRMAN I'M I'M HERE GREAT TEND
INVOLVES DEBT THEN LET ME JUST
REPEAT WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE SIX TWO. A SEVEN THREE
SIX TWO EIGHT THREE THREE IS TO
CODE I'M JUST GOING TO TAKE AS
MANY PEOPLE AS I CAN JUST GIVING
THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND WHAT
THEIR FOR AND AGAINST AND TO BE
HONEST IF THEY START TO GIVE A
SPEECH ALL JUST GO TO THE NEXT
CALLER. ALSO MODERATOR OVER.
YEAH CERTAINLY OF THE FIRST LINE
THAT WE HAVE IS- LINE NUMBER
SIXTEEN. PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND THE AFFILIATION FOR THE
RECORD. ONE SIXTEEN. YOU COULD
BE ON MUTE. RIGHT NOW CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION.
THANK YELL KATRINA THEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY WE SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR SHOULD SHE GET
MULTI YEAR FUNDING PROPOSAL AND
THE ALLOCATION OF THREE HUNDRED
SEVEN POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE UC. TO GROW CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENT INVOLVEMENT IN ACCESS
AND THE ACCOMPANYING DATA
SERVICE THAT'S A THAT'S A THAT'S
A RUN ON SENTENCE AND SO WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY WE'RE
GOING TO GO. ON TO THE NEXT
PERSON MODERATOR. THERE ARE NO
PERSON LINE NUMBER TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU KAREN
LAYERED AND MEMBERS CAMPANELLI
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION-
WE APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE OF
ON GOING COMMITMENT TO ENSURING
THAT ARE YOU YOU HAVE INCREDIBLE
RESEARCH OPPORTUNITIES TO HELP
THE STATE ADDRESS MANY IMPORTANT
ISSUES FACING OUR STATE. WE
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON SUPPORTING AN
INCREASE AT ANNUAL APPLICATION
OF TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS PER.
LABOR CENTER. THAT'S GREAT I WAS
TRYING TO GET YOU TO BE RELEASES
ON GONNA GO TO. TWELVE MAY FOR
THE WAY CENTER THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COM AND I'M GONNA GIVE
EVERYBODY A RIGHT TO. WRITE US
WITH MORE DETAILS IF THEY NEED
TO MODERATOR NEXT CALLER THANK
YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS. NEXT
LINE IS LINE NUMBER THIRTY TWO
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION FOR THE RECORD. HI
MY NAME IS ALEX NILES ON THE
CHAIR OF GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
FOR THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION
AND I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
THREE BUDGET ITEMS TO BE AS
REQUESTED. THE PERSON TWENTY TWO
NINE NINE ONGOING FUNDING FOR
USING SHAPE OUR PROGRAMS THE
SECOND IS FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ONGOING FUNDING FOR THE UC'S ON
DOCUMENTS YOUR PROGRAMS AND
LASTLY IS FOUR MILLION I'M GOING
FUNDING FOR. THE UC'S
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS INITIATIVE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE AND
APOLOGIZE FOR THE BREVITY THAT
YOU HAD TO DO WILL GO ON
MODERATOR TO NEXT CALLER. NEXT
LINE IS THIRTY FOUR PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION FOR
THE RECORD. HI THERE MY NAME'S
MICHAEL SON- UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENT AT UCSD ON BEHALF OF
UTSA AND UNDERSTOOD THE COMMON
IN SUPPORT OF THOSE THREE
PROGRAMS UNDOCUMENTED AND
PROGRAMS AND A CONNECTION
INITIATIVE AND STATE TAX- YOU
KNOW THESE PROGRAMS THAT IMPROVE
MEMORY THANK YOU KNOW LET ME
THANK YOU FOR IT LET ME THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS YOU STATED
WHAT YOU IN SUPPORT. WE'RE
TRYING TO GET EVERYBODY IN. AND
YOU CAN WRITE US AN EXTENDER
COMMENTS. THANK YOU MODERATOR
NEXT COUPLE THANK YOU. THE NEXT
ONE IS NUMBER TWELVE THE YOUR
NAME IN ORDER. FOR THE RECORD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS DANIELLE
ONE DRAW WITH CHILDREN NOW
CALLING ON A FEW ITEMS FIRST
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR SIX MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONGOING FUNDING FOR FOSTER
YOUTH SUPPORT PROGRAMS THAT
UC'S. ON SUPPORT FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INVESTMENT IN
UC'S BASED BUDGET AN ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
BUT CONCERNED ABOUT THE LACK OF
DETAIL REGARDING THE COMPACT AND
HOW IT WILL BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
TO ADDRESSING ISSUES OF EQUITY
IN ACCESS AND FINALLY WE SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
INVEST IN ADDITIONAL STUDENT
HOUSING. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE- NEXT CALL WITH
MODERATE. EXLINE IS NUMBER
THIRTY EIGHT. LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS ELIZABETH VIANNA AND THE
PROGRAM COUNSELOR FOR THE
RENAISSANCE SCHOLARS PROGRAM I
UC SANTA CRUZ FULL IN FULL
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR SIX MILLION DOLLARS
AND ONGOING FUNDING FOR FOSTER
YOUTH PROGRAMS THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALWAYS
HAPPY TO HEAR FROM A SLOG A
MODERATOR NEXT COMMON. SIX LINE
IS THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
LOS COOLER UNDERGRADUATE DEGREE
AT UCF ON BEHALF OF YOU YES. I
AM IN SUPPORT OF THE ON GOING
FUNDING FOR UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT
PROGRAM THE DOCUMENT IS COLOR
INDICATED AND PAPER PROGRAM.
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. MODERATOR NEXT CALLER
. SIX LINE IS THREE SIX PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
FOR THE RECORD. HI MY NAME IS
TERRA POTTER AND I AM A JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOU WE
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR SIX MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONGOING FUNDING FOR FOSTER
YOUTH SUPPORT PROGRAMS AT THE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. SIX LINE
IS THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
BRITTANY FROM UC RIVERSIDE
OFFICE OF BAUCHI SUPPORT
SERVICES I'M A GRADUATE STUDENT
COORDINATOR AND I SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S. PROPOSAL FOR SIX
MILLION AN ONGOING FUNDING FOR
FOSTER YOUTH SUPPORT PROGRAM
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT
COLOR. THE NEXT LINE IS LINE
FIFTEEN PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION FOR THE RECORD
. GOOD MORNING THIS IS JORDAN
SAYS A CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION OR
C. YC WE ARE CALLING TO SUPPORT
GOVERNOR'S NUISANCE PROPOSAL FOR
SIX MILLION DOLLARS AND ONGOING
FUNDING FOR FOX USED TO PROGRAMS
THAT SUPPORT PROGRAM AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE COMMENTS MODERATOR
NEXT CALL. THE NEXT LINE IS
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MR- THIS IS MY SON WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S FUNDING FOR THE
PROXY USE PROGRAM WE ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO SEE A FUNDING FOR-
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS INITIATIVE
AND THE ON DOCUMENTATION
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS YOU THINK OF
PROGRAMS OPPORTUNITY AND A HALF
MILLION. HE MADE ON GOING FROM
LAST YEAR'S ONE TIME APPLICATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER. THE NEXT LINE IS TO.
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
CHARLIE CAN BE HEARD ON THE
PROGRAM COORDINATOR FOR THE
BERKELEY HOPE COLLEGE AT UC
BERKELEY I AM EXPRESSING MY
SUPPORT FOR FUNDING INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
FOR SIX MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONGOING FUNDING FOR POLICY
SUPPORT PROGRAMS AT UC THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A MODERATOR
NEXT CALLER. THE NEXT LINE IS
NUMBER NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO GABLE
CALVIN UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT AT
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA BERKELEY
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF APPROVING
THE FULL POST ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. WITH SPECIAL
EMPHASIS ON FUNDS EARMARKED FOR
BASIC FOOD NEEDS THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. THE NEXT
LINE IS SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS DR- AND I'M
NO LONGER THAT NUMBER IN
PRESIDENT OF SOUTH W. T.
RIVERSIDE I ASK THAT YOU SUPPORT
YOU SEE TWENTY YEAR BUT IN THE
STATE BUDGET THANK YOU THANK YOU
WE APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. THE NEXT
LINE IS FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS MICHELLE ANDREWS WITH
ASSOCIATED STUDENTS OF UC DAVIS
AND THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION-
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION AND ONGOING
FUNDING FOR THE- PROGRAM FOR
MILLION AT AN UNDER ON GOING
FUNDING FOR THE- UNDERGROUND
DOLLARS INITIATIVE. AND FIVE
MILLION AND ONGOING FUNDING FOR
THAT DOCUMENT IT IN A PROGRAM
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS A MODERATOR
NEXT CALL. THE NEXT LINE IS
FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS WITH THE SAYING I AM A
UTILITY STAFF MEMBER AND CURRENT
STAFF INVITED THE BOARD OF
REGENTS AND I AM CALLING TO ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT THE UC FUNDING
REQUEST IN THE STATE BUDGET
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU SO
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR CALL
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. IN HAVE
LAST LINE HERE OF NOT LINE
NUMBER FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS VALERIE GARCIA AND THE
PROGRAM COORDINATOR AT UC DAVIS-
FOR A GUARDIAN SCHOLARS PROGRAM.
ON BEHALF OF THE STUDENTS AND
MYSELF I AM IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING
FUNDING FOR COST YOU CALL
PROGRAMS AT UC. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
AND MODERATOR IS THAT IT. MISTER
CHAIRMAN THAT IS IT THAT THAT IS
THE LAST MONEY LET ME LET ME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
FOR A BEARING WITH US ON THIS
END LET ME THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT JUST TESTIFIED.
BRIEFLY WITH YOU IF YOU WISH TO-
EXTEND YOUR COMMENTS WE WOULD BE
HAPPY TO RECEIVE THEM IT IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE ONE YOU CAN
VISIT OUR WEBSITE AND FIGURE
THAT OUT IF PEOPLE WERE NOT ABLE
TO TESTIFY. AND THEY WOULD LIKE
TO DO THAT. WE INVITE THEM TO DO
THE SAME THING I'D LIKE TO THANK
EVERYBODY WHO PARTICIPATED IN
TODAY'S HEARING IT WAS VERY
SUBSTANTIVE WE GOT TOO MANY
TOPICS WE WENT DOWN. IN DEPTH
AND IT IS REALLY CLEAR THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED HIS BUDGET
WE ARE AIRING IT OUT IN TEN
HEARINGS THIS BEING ONE. AND
THAT- WE WILL WORK TOWARD THE
MAY REVISED IN THE BUDGET IN
JUNE TAKING INTO ACCOUNT. A LOT
OF THE ISSUES THAT WERE
DISCUSSED AND THE TESTIMONY THAT
WAS RECEIVED. ARMS SO AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY'S
PARTICIPATION AND THEIR PATIENTS
WITH WITH OUR PROCESS WE'VE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR TODAY'S
HEARING THE SENATE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW SUB SUB COMMITTEE
NUMBER. ONE IS ADJOURNMENT.